Auch der Rasenfunk sagt jetzt mal ordentlich Schalke. Die Königsblauen sind Zweitligameister und kehren in die Bundesliga zurück. Doch wer folgt Schalke nach oben? Und für welchen Club neben Preußen Münster, wie wir jetzt wissen, endet die Saison im Abstieg? All das, was ihr vor dem letzten Spieltag der 2. Bundesliga der Männer wissen müsst, bespreche ich nun mit Eva-Lotta Bohle. Let's go!
Schon im Programm? Der Rasenfunk.
Langeheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und aufs Bug ist oben! Rossi zu kurz ab wäre lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das 1 zu 0. Markus Kort aus dem Gewühl.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Und damit herzlich willkommen zum Rasenfunk, genauer gesagt zur Ligatur und noch genauer gesagt zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Wir melden uns ein letztes Mal vor dem Saisonende. Mein Name ist Marc, ich führe heute wieder durch diese schöne Zweitligasendung. Ich bin Freier Journalist. Ihr hört mich hier, ihr lest mich am ABB, ihr hört mich bei Hertha Bass. Aber viel wichtiger ist doch, mit wem ich das hier mache, denn es schließt sich ein Kreis. Denn vor Saisonbeginn haben wir eine Saisonprognose als dynamisches Duo aufgenommen, wirklich nur gut gealterte Takes gemacht, glaube ich. Also da ist alles gut gealtert. Da braucht man gar nicht mehr reinhören, weil eigentlich haben wir die Saison noch schon vorgesagt. Und wir sind zum anderen nämlich Eva-Lotta Bohle. Ich grüße dich.
Hallo Marc. Ja, es gab schon bei mir persönlich bessere Laune als am vorletzten Spieltag. Es ist mal wieder, also jeder Verein, der im Abstiegskampf gerade ist, hat es, glaube ich, einfach nicht leicht und möchte einfach, dass die Saison jetzt zu Ende ist am liebsten. Also je nachdem, auf welchem Tabellenplatz man steht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, frag mal die Vierter.
Ja, frag die Bielefelder genauso. Aber ja, ich freue mich sehr, dass wir das zusammen machen und zusammen ein bisschen leiden können vielleicht. Ähm, mehr oder weniger.
Du, ich spüre seit 17 Spieltagen nichts mehr. Also von daher habe ich heftig hier durch.
Vorrang. Und ich kann sagen, nachdem ich heute, ich glaube, sieben Bundesliga-Partien gesehen habe, in sechseinhalb, kann ich sagen, ja.
Also Schalke wird auch Erstligameister, da gibt es keinen Unterschied.
Ja, genau. Also nach dem, was ich da jetzt gesehen habe, Bayern muss sich warm anziehen in der nächsten Saison, Schalke, also das wird schon was.
Ich traue dir mittlerweile alles zu. Ihr den Geko, holt nochmal den Meistertitel. Ich sehe es. So, wir wollen heute zusammen auf den 33. Spieltag zurückblicken, aber auch auf das Saisonfinale vorausblicken, um euch möglichst gut einen Überblick darüber zu geben. Was geht denn noch am 34. Spieltag der 2. Bundesliga? Ich sage mal so viel, holt die Taschenrechner raus, es wird interessant. Dementsprechend haben wir eben die zwei Schwerpunkte. Wir blicken einerseits aufs Aufstiegsrennen und auf die Frage, wer neben Schalke aufsteigen kann. Und andererseits richtet sich unser Blick nach unten. Dort steht mit Münster nun auch ein Absteiger fest. Da sprechen wir auch gleich drüber und wir wollen drauf blicken, welche Teams da auch noch Aktien drin haben. Es sind so einige. Und dementsprechend würde ich sagen, starten wir rein. Aber bevor wir sportlich werden, natürlich noch einmal erwähnt. Ihr kennt das, der Rasenfunk ist werbe-, Paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Er finanziert sich allein durch Spenden. Dieses Mal genannt Florian Coupon, JJ Marcel aus Wien und Hannes, die unterstützen diesen Podcast finanziell. Wenn ihr das auch tun wollt, dann guckt doch mal auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclubvorbei. Da findet ihr alle Infos. Finanziert nicht nur Maxis Lebensunterhalt, sondern macht auch möglich, dass wir diese Nummer hier aufnehmen können. Und das ist doch eine Unterstützung wert. So, starten wir rein in Lage der Liga. Denn bevor wir uns jetzt aufmachen in den Auf- und Abschließkampf bzw. aufmachen in die Teams, um für die es noch um was geht, wollen wir über die beiden Teams reden, damit wir tatsächlich wissen, für uns geht es in der 2. Liga nicht weiter, entweder als positives oder negativ. Und beginnen wollen wir natürlich mit der Positivmeldung. Es hat sich angebahnt auch schon in den letzten Episoden dieses Formats, aber nun ist es eben offiziell und deswegen wollen wir uns noch einmal würdigen. Der FC Schalke 04 ist 2. Liga-Meister und damit auch zurück in der Bundesliga. Eva, was sind deine fast schon abschließenden Worte zu dieser Schalke-Saison, wenn man so möchte? Es ist zwar noch einen Tag Spieltag zu spielen, aber man hat jetzt auch schon gesehen, beim Spiel gegen Nürnberg ein bisschen Alkohol ist drin, eher Ibiza im Kopf als alles andere. Also blicken wir auf das, was davor war.
Ja, man muss, glaube ich, einfach sagen, im Endeffekt war es einfach folgerichtig, weil man über die Saison hinaus dann halt wirklich immer die Ergebnisse geholt hat, auch wenn vielleicht gerade in der Hinrunde die Spiele nicht immer die Besten zum Anschauen waren. Aber da muss man ja auch wirklich nochmal sagen, dass sich Muslice im Winter hingestellt hat, gesagt, ja, okay, wir holen so unsere Punkte, aber vielleicht werden wir ein bisschen zu ausrechenbar hinten raus. Das wollen wir uns nicht vorwerfen lassen und dann eben dieses Risiko eingegangen ist. Natürlich sehr, sehr starke Wintertransfers auch noch gemacht haben. Und wir dann damals ja so ein bisschen spekuliert haben, natürlich auch ein bisschen provokant. Hatsaschiest du dir jetzt so ein bisschen das Mannschaftsgefüge, geht das so auf. Und man muss sagen, es ist am Ende aufgegangen. Die letzten fünf Partien vor diesem Nürnbergspiel alle gewonnen. Also das ist schon eine deutliche Leistung und halt eben genau das gezeigt, was ihre Konkurrenz dann im Ausstiegskampf eben nicht mehr hinbekommen hat auf Strecke. Und sie haben eben die wichtigen Partien meistens zumindest nicht verloren, auch wenn gegen Hannover und Darmstadt Unentschieden dabei waren. Aber trotzdem vor allem natürlich auch der Sieg gegen Paderborn und so. Das war natürlich wichtig und ich glaube, man kann wirklich sagen, als ich Glück nun Schalke, wir haben tatsächlich in unserer Gruppe so ein bisschen geguckt, wer hatte Schalke? Denn eigentlich alles so. Also der Ausstiegskandidat auf dem Zettel, die Antwort könnte sie verstören, weil ich glaube, es war genau keiner.
Exakt, ich habe auch nochmal sehr genau geguckt, wirklich niemand.
Im Forum waren so ein bisschen, da waren es glaube ich 25 Prozent, die zumindest Schalke als Aufsteiger getippt haben. Also Respekt davor auf jeden Fall schon mal. Aber da muss man wirklich sagen, also Hut ab. Ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt, um vielleicht schon mal einen Blick auf die nächste Saison zu werfen. Was da kadertechnisch passiert, was natürlich auch, also wie man das Ganze angeht. Man weiß ja auch, wie Schalke dann damals auch direkt wieder abgestiegen ist. Ich wage schon mal die Prognose, ich glaube nicht, dass das passiert, weil das Fundament einfach ein ganz anderes ist als damals. Aber wir bleiben gespannt. Was ist dein Take dazu?
Ja, in Kurzform um die Saison jetzt wirklich nicht im Detail nochmal komplett nachzubesprechen, muss die Erzählung tatsächlich bei Frank Baumann beginnen. Also beziehungsweise eigentlich bei der Gremienarbeit, die letztendlich Frank Baumann verpflichtet hat. Der spawnt ja nicht plötzlich auf Schalke, sondern der muss ja irgendwie auch geholt worden sein. Diese Verpflichtung hat sich als absoluter Glücksgriff letztendlich entpuppt. Natürlich, wenn man darauf geguckt hat und auf die letzten Jahre Schalke, musste man kein Experte sein, um festzustellen, ja, der könnte diesem Umfeld gut tun mit seiner Erfahrung, mit dieser, ja, der ist ja auch wirklich ein sehr unaufgeregter Typ. Das wurde ihm ja teilweise in Bremen fast schon vorgeworfen, dass er fast zu langweilig war. Aber für dieses Umfeld extrem wichtig gewesen. Und dann entpuppt sich die Trainerpersonalien als fast noch größerer Glücksgriff. Das muss man sich noch mal vorstellen. Damals im Sommer holen sie einen Miron Muslitsch, der in Deutschland gar keine Lobby hatte. Niemand kannte ihn. Und dann zahlen die sogar eine Ablöse für jemanden, der in der 2. Liga provokant gesagt mit der 2. Liga in England abgestiegen ist, dass das auch daran lag, dass das Gefühl nicht mehr retten konnte, was da fabriziert wurde, steht erst mal auf einem anderen Blatt. Erst mal war die Stimmung vorsichtig bis sehr skeptisch. Da muss ich sagen, also meine Tabellenplatzierung, die altern wirklich überhaupt nicht gut. Die altern wirklich wie Milch. Das kann ich ganz offen zugeben. Aber ich habe damals vor einem Jahr einen Post auf Blue Sky abgesetzt, wo ich geschrieben habe, haltet mich für verrückt, das kann ganz schlecht altern, aber Miron Muzlic, das könnte richtig gut werden auf Schalke. Ich hatte so ein Gefühl und das altert ganz gut und ich glaube, das lag damals daran, das habe ich nach seinen ersten, glaube ich, PKs und so gepostet, weil ich das Gefühl hatte, das eine, was du auf Schalke sein musst, ist natürlich erstmal ein guter Trainer, handwerklich, aber du musst vor allen Dingen ein guter Kommunikator sein. Und das muss man Miron Muzlic lassen, ist er absolut ein fantastischer Kommunikator. Er wirkt manchmal, wir hatten das auch schon, auch da in der viel besagten WhatsApp-Gruppe, ich habe es schon mal gesagt, seine Sätze wirken manchmal fast wie gebaut, so, es hat dann fast was roboterhaftiges, weil er wirklich keinem irgendwie auf den Schlips treten will und dann lässt er sich pausen und es wirkt dann monoton, aber er kriegt es irgendwie immerhin, den Schliff Menschlichkeit wieder mit reinzuwerfen oder mal den einen oder anderen Joke oder so, sodass es eben doch nicht komplett so wirkt und da hat er seinen Vorgängern viel voraus, er hat diese Mannschaft komplett angezündet, ihr in der Hinrunde ein defensives Fundament gegeben, in der Rückrunde sich pragmatisch gezeigt und gesagt, ey, das wird nicht reichen, wir müssen offensiver werden, das was du angesprochen hast, Eva, hat die Neuzugänge fantastisch integriert. Also da reden wir ja nicht nur über einen Dzeko, sondern auch wie ein Aoi Shih, der plötzlich zum Leistungsträger wurde. Fantastisch. Und am Ende wird da die Arbeit belohnt, die man im Sommer gemacht hat, wo man sich mit auch diesem Scouting-Tool, was man da aufgesetzt hat, eine sehr klare Philosophie geschaffen hat, mit sehr klarem Blick auf Stärken und Schwächen dieser Mannschaft im Winter grandios nachgelegt und diese vielen besonderen Geschichten auch, ob man Loris Karius nimmt, ob man einen Bäcker nimmt, der im Sommer noch mal zurückkommt zu seiner Liebe und sagt, das kriegen wir jetzt irgendwie gerade gebogen. Karaman, der noch mal wieder völlig aus der Asche da irgendwie emporsteigt als Kapitän. Elfer Uzi, der dieses Juwel ist, was die bei Aachen finden. Dzeko, der im Winter sagt, Schalke mache ich. Das ist schon geil. Also dementsprechend bitter für die 2. Liga, dass man Schalke verliert. Aber sie kehren an ihren amtlichen Platz zurück.
Ja, man muss ja auch noch sagen, also wir hatten ja eh, das hatten wir zu Beginn der Saison auch gesprochen. Wir hatten 8 Trainer in dieser Liga, die diese Liga noch nicht kannten, was ich bei 18 Vereinen weiterhin auch eine große Nummer finde. Und wir können ja mal so ein bisschen drüber gucken, wie viele Trainer haben es denn auch geschafft. Und das zeigt ja auch nochmal, wie schwierig es auch ist. Je nachdem, ob du auch neu dazukommst, wie ein Markus Fiedler beispielsweise.
Schon wieder vergessen gefühlt.
Wie ein Adel Ex Endo und so, die halt neu dazukommen. Und zum Teil auch ganz neu, also die vorher auch bei ihren Vereinen auch noch nicht tätig waren. Oder du hast halt, na klar, einen Stamm, einen Knier, die halt eben mit ihren Vereinen aufgestiegen sind. Das ist dann natürlich auch nochmal eine andere Dynamik. Aber das finde ich auch so interessant, wenn wir eben da drauf geguckt haben. Und deshalb war es, glaube ich, natürlich trotzdem immer noch ein sehr großes Risiko, mit Muslice zu gehen. Und für uns trotzdem, glaube ich, einfach schwierig eins zu schätzen. Gerade weil es doch auch nach dieser Kees-Fan-Wonder-Geschichte und so natürlich auch einen, ich sag mal in Anführungszeichen, Griff ins Klo hätte sein können, wieder jemanden zu nehmen, den man nicht hat. Aber ich sage das auch gerne nochmal, das habe ich schon tausendmal gesagt. Dafür ist auch der Pool an Trainern, die du aus der 2. Liga picken kannst, der ist halt wirklich schwierig. Welche Trainer tun sich das überhaupt an? Und von daher muss man wirklich Schalke gratulieren. Ich meine, dass man jetzt 3-0 gegen Nürnberg verloren hat. Visuell der Freundschaft ist, glaube ich, geschenkt. Man muss ja auch trotzdem sagen, liebe Grüße an Lisa Höfer, die war im Stadion am Samstagabend, die da meinte, es wäre einfach eine unfassbare Atmosphäre gewesen. Auch so eine gegenseitige Wertschätzung. Und man muss ja auch mal sagen, bei den ganzen Bildern, vielleicht auch bei den Negativbildern, die zum Teil produziert wurden in dieser Liga, ist das ja auch ein sehr schönes Zeichen, dass eine Freundschaft, die auf Fan-Basis besteht, womit Spieler, die seit einem halben Jahr oder einem Jahr bei dem Verein spielen, ob das jetzt Nürnberg oder Schalke ist, vielleicht erstmal weniger mit anfangen können. Brauchen wir uns jetzt nichts vorzumachen, dass da jeder Spieler genau weiß, eigentlich wechselt zu Schalke, die haben eine Fan-Friendschaft mit dem 1. FCN. Aber dass das dann auch so mitgetragen wird von Spielern, beider Vereine, das ist natürlich auch ein ganz schönes Zeichen, wie ich fand.
Absolut. Und ich möchte nochmal betonen, ich fand es sehr schön, dass sich auf Schalke alle dran gehalten haben und der Platz nicht gestürmt wurde. Ich halte von Platzstürmen generell nicht so viel. Manchmal entstehen sie aus der Emotion, aber so ein bisschen wie bei Moschplitz und Konzerten. Mittlerweile macht es jeder, weiß ich auch nicht. Und es gab ja, wie gesagt, sehr gute Gründe, die die Schalke-Verantwortlichen angeführt haben, warum man es nicht machen sollte. Ich finde es aber auch gleichzeitig schön. Du kannst auf den Rängen trotzdem alles abreißen. Und die Spieler haben auf dem Feld den Platz, den sie brauchen zum Feiern. Sie können ihre Familie dazu holen. Das ist bei Platzstimmen überhaupt nicht möglich. Sogar ein Sicherheitsrisiko. Also das fand ich auch produziert in der Regel die schöneren Bilder, wie ich finde, weil du nimmst den Spielern in dem Moment alles, wenn du zu Tausends auf die zuläufst. Und alle wollen Stück von diesen Menschen gerade haben. Ich tue mich da immer sehr, sehr schwer. Das fand ich gut, wie es auf Gelsenkirchen gelöst wurde.
Obwohl ich sagen muss, also bevor hier jetzt Freiburger zuhören und uns hier in wieviele Türen einlaufen. Ich fand das in Freiburg, das war auch sehr respektvoll. Also wurde einmal kurz, gerade von einer tiefen Fanszene, der Platz gestört, um abend und direkt wieder zurück. Ich glaube, manchmal darf man dann auch nicht, also wir sind dann ja als Fans, glaube ich, Marc. Manchmal denkt man dann ja auch kurz nicht rational. Ich weiß auch, wie es in Bielefeld war, als man den Pokalfinaleinzug geschafft hat. Manchmal gerade stehende Leute in den Kurven. Das ist dann manchmal, also der Finaleinzug ist, glaube ich, immer auch noch mal anders zu bewerten, bei allem Respekt als ein Aufstieg. Aber du hast natürlich vollkommen recht. Und das zeigt eben auch, das möchte ich noch mal kurz unterstreichen, mit der allgemeinen Kommunikation, die bei Schalke 04 vorherrscht. Das war echt gut und da darfst du halt auch einem Matthias Tillmann neben, aber auch Frank Baumann, Yuri Molder, auch eine Christina Röhl-Hamas, die dieses ganze Thema Finanzen– Die stille Heldin, muss man echt sagen, ja. Genau, die das super behandelt und das darf man, glaube ich, da auch immer nicht unter, also einfach unter das Dischkern, so ich wollte unter das Kissen legen, zu sagen, dass es nicht das richtige Sprüche wird. Pass ist der Zahn und die Zahnfet, naja. Aber genau, also ich glaube, wir haben dann jetzt Schalke doch noch mal etwas ausführlicher gelobt, aber sie haben es tatsächlich auch verdient und sind auch vollkommen verdient 2. Ligameister.
Und nach wie vor, für Rüddy, waren letztes Jahr irgendwie drei Punkte da von den Pferd abzusteigen. Das kann man sich wirklich, das muss man sich nur fair gegenwärtigen. Das ist absurd. Aber apropos absteigen, dann kommen wir von den schönen Bildern zu den traurigen Bildern. Man hat schon einige Tränen bei den Münsterspielern gesehen. Preußen Münster ist nun offiziell abgestiegen. Und ich, ja, man tut sich ein bisschen damit schwer. Mit 30 Punkten nach 33 Spielen ist die Nummer jetzt durch. Und damit auch die Drittliga-Rückkehr nach zwei Jahren Zweitliga steht damit fest. Münster wird diese Liga, das steht auch schon fest, als Sabin letzter verlassen. Also das ist nicht mehr aufzuholen, denn Fird hat 34 Punkte. Ja, ich blicke ein bisschen mit Wehmut auf diese Saison zurück, weil ich es schade finde, dass etwas nicht belohnt wurde, was mit viel Mut angefangen hat. Man hat im Sommer, nachdem man ja– wir erinnern uns an diese verrückte Kommo mit Christian Panda und so weiter– als man letztes Saison den Abstieg noch verhinderte, hat man im Sommer den Komplettumbruch gewagt, hat eine mutige Entscheidung getroffen mit Alexander Ende, der von FAIR kam, hat den Kader komplett umgebaut und gesagt, ne, wir wollen jetzt hier nicht wie Braunschweig oder so, das werden sie nicht gesagt haben, aber so ist es ja, nicht hier das ja einfach nur überleben, sondern wir wollen jetzt auch eine Identität schaffen. Das fand ich cool, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Und letztendlich hat es für mich auch so gewirkt in Kurzform auf einer Ergebniskrise folgte schleichend eine Leistungskrise und dann fehlte auch durch Verletzungen schlussendlich die Substanz im Kader, um sich da nochmal gegenzustellen und dann kriegt das so eine eklige Eigendynamik. Bist oft gar nicht so weit weg, aber nie so richtig nah dran und auch ein Alois Schwarz hat dann mit, ich hab nochmal nachgeguckt, vier Unentschieden und zwei Niederlagen nicht die Lösung gefunden für das Problem, das Münster hatte, nämlich man kann einfach keine Spiele gewinnen. Und dann steigst du am Ende irgendwie verdient ab, auch wenn es lange Zeit gar nicht unbedingt so danach aussah.
Ja, ein einziger Sieg in der Rückrunde und das war gegen Eintracht Braunschweig am 24. Spieltag. Das, also, braucht man jetzt kein Genie sein, um zu sagen, das reicht einfach nicht. Wir haben in der einen Folge schon darüber diskutiert, ob und wie der Zeitpunkt richtig war, Alex Ende zu entlassen und dann ausgerechnet Alois Schwarz zu holen. Die Stabilisierung der Defensive, das wäre etwas gewesen, das hätte man, wenn, ich glaube, um einiges früher anvisieren müssen. Dafür war die Zeit jetzt einfach zu kurz. Und ich sage das gerne nochmal, Alois Schwarz glaube ich wirklich einfach nicht der Trainer, der da dann im dem Moment die richtigen Offensivideen hat und vielleicht auch so eine Mannschaft, also respektvoll gesagt, aber vielleicht nicht der beste Motivator in so einem Moment. Sie hat natürlich jetzt auch eine isoliert betrachtet, ein 3-3 gegen Hannover, ein 1-1 gegen Darmstadt, sind vor allem in Unterzahl gegen Darmstadt, Liedberg fast schießt noch einen Elfmeter, man da auch sagen muss, also, war auch schlecht geschossen, I get it, aber last time I checked, ist das egal, wie ein Elfmeter geschossen wird, wenn er aufs Tor kommt und der Torhüter hält ihn und er steht aber vor der Linie, dann wird dieser Elfmeter eigentlich wiederholt. Aber gut, und du hattest aber schon also dieses 4-1 gegen Schalke mal rausgenommen, aber du hattest schon im Schmink gegen Bielefeld das Gefühl, dieses Spiel zu verlieren, nach der frühen Führung. Das war schon so der erste Sargnagel, ehrlich gesagt. Und dann eben hinten raus gegen Hannover, nah dran zu sein, zu führen gegen Darmstadt, das beschreibt diese Saison eigentlich auch sehr, sehr gut. Es ist natürlich bitter, dass du eben gerade dann auch diesen Stadion-Neubau hast. Es war jetzt das letzte Spiel, also eben auch mit der anderen Tribüne, wo bisher eben die Ultrasets auch waren, wo es früher der Gäste-Block war. Das ist natürlich echt bitter, weil wir wissen auch alle, so ein Drittliga-Abschriek, der tut richtig weh und das ist auf gar keinen Fall ein Selbstläufer, dass du das Jahr darauf wieder hochgehst. Ganz liebe Grüße an Ulm beispielsweise, die jetzt Herr Beuth abgestimmt sind. Und ich glaube, das ist halt wirklich– Münster muss im Sommer ganz, ganz schnell gucken, wie sie die neue Saison angehen. Weil ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass du mit Alois Schwarz weitermachen wirst. Also das wäre für mich ein fatales Zeichen, ehrlich gesagt. Aber dafür hat man jetzt, ich sag mal in Anführungszeichen, einen Vorteil im Gegensatz zu ungefähr 8.000 anderen Vereinen in dieser Liga, dass du eben jetzt halt– und ehrlich gesagt ja schon etwas länger weißt, muss man ja ganz ehrlich sagen. Also die Zeichen standen ja jetzt schon ein bisschen länger auf Abstieg. Und vielleicht da schon ein, zwei Weichen stellen konntest, schon ein paar Gespräche führen konntest mit aktuellen Spielern, potenziell mit neuen. Das wird vielleicht ein kleiner– in Anführungszeichen– Vorteil sein, den sie gegenüber anderen Mannschaften haben.
Und du hast gerade gesagt, bei Schalke ist das Fundament ein anderes. Ich finde, bei Preußen Münster macht mir das Fundament auch keine Sorgen. Das ist ein finanziell sehr sauber geführter Verein, muss man sagen. Da sahen die letzten Zahlen– ich hatte das mal für einen Vorbericht oder so– mit jemandem besprochen aus Münster. Die Zahlen sahen richtig gut aus im Geschäftsbericht. Dieses neue Stadion steht, die Verantwortlichen haben mit der Verpflichtung von Alexander Ende gezeigt, dass sie bereit sind, auch ein bisschen progressivere Entscheidungen zu treffen, sagen wir mal so. Also ich mache mir stand jetzt keine Riesen Sorgen, dass Münster in ein krasses Loch fallen könnte. Die haben das Geld jetzt in der 2. Liga mitgenommen, haben damit Infrastruktur und so weiter ausgebaut. Das war klug. Jetzt muss man gucken, was vom Kader übrig bleibt. Da sind ja auch ein paar Spieler erst im Sommer gekommen. Kann ich mir schon vorstellen, das weiß ich nicht. Marvin Schulz oder so sagt, weißt du was, ich fühle mich jetzt hier eigentlich ganz wohl und die Riesenlobby in der 2. Liga habe ich auch nicht mehr. Komm, ich mache es mit. Also das ist immer die Frage, wie weit fällt so ein Kader auseinander und wie viel muss zu ersetzen. Aber grundsätzlich war, glaube ich, Münster eher ein Gewinn als ein Verlust für die 2. Liga in diesen zwei Jahren. Das ist ja auch schon eine gewachsene Fanszene. Man hatte ein paar Derbys auch in der Liga. Also ein bisschen Hitze war auch drin. Also ordentliche zwei Jahre. Der Mut wurde jetzt nicht belohnt im zweiten Jahr. Ich wollte ihn aber nochmal loben, weil ich das immer schön finde, wenn Vereine da eine Idee formulieren und ich sage, ja, wieder Platz 15 war, finde ich ganz nett. Gut, und dann würde ich sagen, gehen wir jetzt in die einzelnen Vereine rein, für die es noch um etwas geht. Und wir beginnen, wir machen es in tabellarischer Reihenfolge. Das ergibt einfach am meisten Sinn. Auch wenn man natürlich sagen kann, jetzt allein im Aufstiegsrennen, alle haben die gleiche Punktzahl. Das ist schon wieder dieser übliche Zweitligavarense, aber sie haben zumindest unterschiedliche Tordifferenzen. Und deswegen beginnen wir bei der SV aus Elbersberg. Eva.
Genau, das ist der Platz, zweite Platz nämlich eben, du hast es eben schon gesagt, das sind 59 Punkte. Aber man hat eben mit 61 geschossenen Toren und nur im Verhältnis 39 kassierten Toren das beste Torverhältnis mit plus 22, 17 Siege, 8 Unentschieden und 8 Niederlagen. Es gab jetzt eine 1 zu 3 Niederlage gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf am Sonntag und Marc, ich bin ganz ehrlich mit dir, hättest du mich vor diesem Spieltag gefragt, wer für mich aus diesem 3er Konglumerat Elbersberg, Hannover, Paderborn im Power-Ranking auf dem ersten Platz steht, dann hätte ich gesagt, die SVE, ohne zu wissen, wie Paderborn und Hannover spielen, einfach weil Elbersberg am 32. Spieltag Paderborn mit 5 zu 1 besiegt hat und jetzt einen Auftritt gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf hingelegt hat, wo man wirklich sagen muss, es war, also es klingt sehr hart, aber fast schon unangenehm substanzlos. Also da ging ganz, ganz wenig nach vorne. Man hatte ein Eigentor durch Lejeune Cours.
Sein drittes damit übrigens Rekordhalter.
Ja, und generell Abstimmungsprobleme in der Defensive. Das sah zwischendurch, also zwischendurch fiel es sich ein bisschen nach vertauschen Rollen an. Wir haben das schon oft besprochen, dass Fortuna Düsseldorf natürlich vielleicht auch nicht ein klassischer Abstiegskandidat ist. Die besitzen eben Qualität dem Kader. Aber da wir über Düsseldorf später noch reden, einmal das so ein bisschen zur Seite geschoben. Man ist in der Formtabelle trotzdem auf Platz 8 mit zwei Siegen, einem Unentschieden und zwei Niederlagen. Man muss halt wirklich sagen, es ist eine Niederlage, die kommt halt zum denkbar schlechtesten Zeitpunkt. Und ich weiß nicht, wie dir das geht, aber sie hatten ja, da wir ja leider einen sehr zerstöckelten Spieltag weiterhin haben, das zeigt es eben nochmal gut. Elvesberg hat jetzt die gute Position, die sie innehatten. Sie hätten ja eben heute schon aufsteigen können mit einem Sieg aufgrund der Ergebnisse. Muss man irgendwie sagen, ich fand schon ein bisschen überraschend. Denkst du, das ist dann vielleicht doch so ein bisschen Angst vor dem Aufstieg? Oder mangelnde Erfahrung vielleicht auch in solchen Momenten? Oder wo siehst du generell das Problem?
Also, ich konnte das Spiel nie sehen, weil ich ja das Hertha-Firth-Spiel gesehen habe, besonders um natürlich Firt einmal nochmal mir anzugucken. Dazu kommen wir später noch. Ich kann es mir… also, wir werden heute natürlich in die Küchenpsychologie steppen. Das geht gar nicht anders. Und ich glaube, anders wird es auch nicht zu erklären sein, dass Elvesberg dieses Spiel so verliert. Ich glaube, das wird so ein klassisches Spiel sein, wo du dann nach knapp 20 Minuten kassierst du ja dieses Eigentor. Meine ich. Ab diesen Zeitpunkt, spätestens dann, wirst du dich halt in einem falschen Film befinden und denkst, Moment, aber unser Drehbuch war doch ein anderes. Wir haben doch vorher 5 zu 1, so hast du es gesagt, Paderborn wirklich geschrubbt. Und ich glaube schon, dass selbst in dem medialen, nicht groß aufgepumpten Ort Elvesberg die Spieler mitbekommen, dass natürlich dann geschrieben wird, noch ein Sieg. Noch ein Sieg und die Nummer könnte durch sein. Spätestens nach den Ergebnissen am Freitag, oder an den zwei Tagen vorher, wusstest du, dass es tatsächlich reichen wird, wenn du gewinnst. Und dann läuft das Spiel, oder fängt das Spiel einfach gar nicht so an, wie du möchtest. Und du hast vielleicht eh noch nicht den besten Tag. Und ja, und ich glaube spätestens mit dem 2 zu 0 von Cedric Itten, hast du nicht mehr den Kopf zurückzukommen. So, dann bist du nervös. Dann, wie du gesagt hast, dann gab es ja viele Unsoberkeiten im Spiel. Es war nicht viel Substanz. Und das passt ja gar nicht zu Elbersberg. Denn selbst wenn Elbersberg Spiele verliert, denkst du meistens, aber es sah auf keinen Fall schlecht aus. Und wenn gar nichts passt an dem Tag, dann sind wir natürlich bei einer Kopfsache. Und natürlich kannst du dich sehr, also, Standorte wie Elbersberg oder früher Heidenheim haben ja den Vorteil, dass dieser Druck öffentlich kaum bis gar nicht vorhanden ist. Aber an den letzten zwei Spieltagen wird er da sein. Ist scheißegal, was für ein Standort das ist. Er wird da sein. Wenn du es dann wirklich zupacken kannst, wir haben das auch bei Magdeburg erlebt, natürlich etwas größerer Standort, aber genauso überraschend und eigentlich kein Druck ist, es machen zu müssen, irgendwann kommt er an. Und dann ist der Spielverlauf hier ist. Wer weiß, wie es gewesen wäre, wenn es da relativ lange 0 zu 0 steht oder Elbersberg wirklich diesen einen Angriff, den sie eigentlich immer drin haben, finden, 1 zu 0 Führung gehen, denn schrubben die Düsseldorfer an dem Tag vielleicht 3-0 weg und wir sagen, alles klar, danke schön, hier ist die Bundesliga. Also ich glaube, da kommt Kopf plus blöder Spielverlauf hinzu und dann verlierst du dieses Spiel. Trotzdem muss man ja sagen, dass Elbersberg trotzdem weiterhin alles in eigener Hand hat. Sie haben am letzten Spieltag ein Heimspiel gegen Münster. Das einzige Team gefühlt, bis auf jetzt Karlsruhe und Co., die wissen, dass sie in der zweiten Liga bleiben. Für die, die nun mal durch ist, ja, Münster wird sich nicht verabschieden wollen und die haben eben keinen Druck mehr. Aber es gab schon mal schlechtere Ausgangslagen.
Ja, das Ding war natürlich, also natürlich hatte Elbersberg auch seine Szene im Strafraum. Im Endeffekt stehen auf beiden Seiten zwei Schüsse aufs Tor in diesem Spiel. Das ist dürftig. Ich habe die Fehler schon angesprochen. Und du hast dann aber trotzdem schon gemerkt, dass es für Düsseldorf eben, man muss ja fast so hart sagen, tatsächlich um die Existenz geht, weil wir wissen, bei Düsseldorf kann das wirklich richtig böse enden, wenn die in die 3. Liga absteigen. Und da hast du dann zwischendurch auch gemerkt, da gab es eben Defensivaktionen, da wurde sich wirklich auch dann in die Bälle reingeworfen. Also ich meine, am Ende hatten wir einen XG-Wert von 0,65 zu 0,76. Das Spiel geht 3-1 aus. So Statistiken beschreiben nicht immer ein Spiel. Aber deshalb habe ich eben auch so ein bisschen gesagt, du hast natürlich vollkommen recht, dass das dann auch viel Küchenpsychologie ist, weil selbst wenn du halt statistisch gesehen, wäre das vielleicht ein ausgeglicheneres Spiel. Aber das kann dann gerne mal so sein, dass du eben in so einem Moment, da für die Fortuna und sie sprechen wie gesagt später noch über die Fortuna, es ist halt natürlich dann gerade mit einem Iten nochmal eine andere Schlagkraft, die da irgendwie gegenkommt. Aber ich würde trotzdem auch mit dir mitgehen und sagen so, gut, ich meine die anderen beiden Vereine spielen auch gegen Teams, für die es um nichts mehr geht. Also, ich sage mal in Anführungszeichen ein bisschen einen Vorteil da, aber ja, also ich würde per se Elvesberg, weil sie vielleicht dann doch auch weniger Druck haben, obwohl das halt Paderborn auch. Also da schauen wir mal, wen das am Ende des Tages dann weniger juckt. Aber ja, also ich sehe da trotzdem auch die Qualität, da aber was mich halt so ein bisschen, also im Ende ist es eben auch ein Eigentor von Düsseldorf, also die Qualität der Schüsse, die waren gerade, wie ich fand, in der ersten Halbzeit nicht gut. Deshalb weiß ich, also, weil du einfach bis zum 01 auch relativ wenig offensiv selber gezeigt hast. Aber ich kann schon mal Spoiler Alert, das wird bei dem nächsten Verein, über den wir sprechen, auch der Fall gewesen sein.
Weißt du was, dann überreiche ich dir den Staffelstab erneut und du kannst gerne zu Hannover 96 kommen.
Genau, Hannover 96. Niemand wird es wundern, dass es Platz 3 nach dieser Reihenfolge und auch 59 Punkte sind. Man hat 57 zu 41 Tore, also ein Torverhältnis von plus 16. 16 Siege, 11 unentschieden und 6 Niederlagen stehen zu Buche. Vorm Tabelle ist Platz 3, 2 Siege, 3 unentschieden. Aber ich sage mal so, gerade die letzten beiden Unentschieden gegen Bochum am Samstag und letzte Woche das 3 zu 3 gegen Münster sorgen bei den Hannover-Fans in meinem Umfeld für eine gewisse Unzufriedenheit. Und ich muss ehrlich gesagt sagen, gerade nach diesem 1-1 gegen Bochum auch nicht vollkommen unverständlich, weil da muss man tatsächlich sagen, ja, okay, für Bochum ging es nichts mehr. Ja, die hatten den Klassen halt quasi eben auch schon in der Tasche. Aber das war wirklich über weite Strecken ein nicht schönes Fußballspiel von Hannover. Also auch da hatte ich tatsächlich dann schon auch das Gefühl, da war man dann doch auch irgendwie durch das Unentschieden von Paderborn, dachte man auch, ja, gute Ausgangslage, passt eigentlich ganz gut, wenn wir jetzt hier gewinnen, dann haben wir schon mal vielleicht einen weniger, um den wir uns kümmern müssen. Ja, und dann schießt man zwar das 1 zu 0, aber man muss sagen, das hält keine 5 Minuten oder es hält 5 Minuten. Und da muss man schon sagen, auch das ist dann zum Teil so ein Pattern gewesen fast, was sich so ein bisschen durch die Hannoveraner Saison zwischendurch mal durchgezogen hat, dass man so komplett unerklärliche Leistungsabfälle hatte.
Allein schon innerhalb von Partien, absurde Phasen hatte, ja.
Ja, und da, ich weiß es nicht, wie es dir geht, Marc, aber Hannover ist das ganz große Fragezeichen für mich in diesem Studio.
Das sind sie ja schon die komplette Saison. Sie sind ja diese Wundertüte, weil sie eigentlich, ich finde, per se hat Hannover das Potenzial, die klar beste Mannschaft dieser Liga zu sein. Das haben sie in dieser Saison schon gezeigt. Allein, wie sie in diese Saison reingekommen sind, war ja verrückt nach diesem Riesenumbruch. Und danach waren es immer wieder so Phasen. Und das ist ja das Verrückte, dass sich die Phase gerade gar nicht so gut anfühlt aufgrund der beiden Unentschieden. Aber wenn man mal guckt, wir sind seit 8 Spielen ungeschlagen und hatten in den letzten 15 Partien eine Niederlage, trotzdem fühlt es sich nicht so richtig gut an. Eben aufgrund zu vieler Unentschieden und eben diesen beiden Ergebnissen zuletzt. Und ich glaube, man muss das Bohrum-Spiel ein bisschen zusammen mit diesem Münsterspiel erzählen, weil auch da, das ist teilweise eine Kopfsache, dass du du liegst 0 zu 2 schon mal hinten nach 40 Minuten gegen Münster. Ja, für Münster ging es noch um alles. Trotzdem, zu Hause darfst du dich da gegen den 18. Sohn nicht präsentieren. Dann schaffst du es, aus einem 0 zu 2 in ein 3 zu 2 zu machen. Du machst in der 85. zu Hause das 3 zu 2 und kassierst noch das 3 zu 3. Das darf dir nicht passieren. Und es darf dir eben auch nicht passieren gegen Bohrum, so schnell, wie du gesagt hast, den Gegentreffer, den Ausgleichstreffer zu kassieren. Und dann passiert dir ja auch nichts mehr. Also, ja, ich hab das Gefühl gerade, also auf der einen Seite ist es eine Kopfsache und auf der anderen Seite habe ich das Gefühl, dass ein paar Spieler auch in einem Formloch sind. Also, man muss einfach sagen, dass Kaelmann nicht mehr so gut trifft, wie er es in der Saison zwischenzeitlich getan hat. Ja gut, Bundu ist eh so ein verrückter Spieler. Da macht er irgendwie zwei Tore gegen Münster und den anderen Spielen. Ist er gar nicht aufgetaucht. Ich fand ihn in der Hinrunde insgesamt besser als in der Rückrunde. Jokota zeigt nicht immer mehr das, was er hatte. Und da gibt es natürlich auch so Leute wie Matsuda, der auch herausrein, den die Saison gekommen ist. Und dann kam irgendwie auch nichts mehr. Also irgendwie so eine Mischung aus langsam geht es in die Köpfe. Der üblichen Hannoveraner, ja, fehlenden Souveränität und ein paar Formeln zu viel auf einmal. Also ich glaube nach wie vor auch da, du hast ja in dem Sinne noch alle Möglichkeiten, sie spielen zu Hause gegen Nürnberg. Nürnberg macht das sich aber gerade durchaus zur Aufgabe, noch mal auch Vereine zu ärgern. Also Nürnberg ist gar nicht so schlecht drauf. Jetzt klar, 3-0 gegen Schalke ist ein bisschen in Klammern zu setzen, aber mach das erst mal und auch sonst haben die zuletzt gar nicht so schlechte Spiele gemacht. Also ich erinnere mich da zum Beispiel, genau, die haben ja auch gegen Magdeburg gewonnen und zwischenzeitlich hatten sie dieses 3-0 gegen Lautern am 27. Spieltag. Also so schlecht sind sie nicht drauf. Musst du erst mal schlagen. So ein Team, was aktuell, glaube ich, ganz gut auf so einer Welle reitet, für uns geht es um nichts mehr. Aber ja, auch da gilt, gewinnt du dieses Spiel, bis du aufgrund der Tordifferenz, wenn Paderborn nicht völlig verrückte Dinge tut, definitiv dritter. So, dann haben wir schon im Vorgespräch geklärt, aktuell ist nicht zu sagen, gegen wen sie dann spielen werden. Vielleicht wird es das Niedersachsen-Derby, das wäre natürlich, ja, das wäre hitzig. Aber ja, irgendwie macht mich diese Hannover-Saison selbst als Außenstehende ein bisschen irre, weil ich mir denke, ihr habt eigentlich alle Werkzeuge, von Spielern bis Trainer, um diese Liga eigentlich zu dominieren, und ihr habt das einfach zu oft liegen gelassen. Das zeigen ja auch Dinge wie Expected-Goals-Tabellen und so weiter. Und jetzt, ja, jetzt hat man sich dieses kleine Loch, was ja immer noch ein Positives ist, du kannst immer noch aufsteigen, da haben sie sich aber selbst reingegraben. Und jetzt gilt es irgendwie, das Ding noch über die Zinniere zu bringen, um zumindest die Relegation zu holen. Aber da wissen wir ja auch, wie es Statistische und Zweitligisten dann bestellt ist.
Ja, und also das Ding ist halt einfach, was mir so an Hannover-Stelle ein bisschen Sorgen machen würde, ist, dass man halt einfach zu Hause nicht gut ist, ne? Also 26 Punkte hat man da in 16 Spielen geholt. Ich sag dir mal kurz, die Vereine, die da drum herum liegen, Bochum hat drei Punkte mehr. Moduna-Düsseldorf zwei Punkte weniger. Aminia-Wiedelfeld und Hertha jeweils drei Punkte weniger. Also, und dann gucken wir nochmal, wo der Rest da irgendwie in der Tabelle steht. Das ist halt so ein bisschen schwierig. Und wenn wir uns halt das Hinspiel gegen Bochum angucken, hattest du ja unfassbar viele Torchancen, bist super häufig an einem hervorragenden Timo Horn gescheitert, hast da 0-0 gespielt, wenn der den Elfmeter noch verschossen hat. Und wenn man dann halt denkt, gut, damals hat man dann gegen Nürnberg, da war man per se ja auch die bessere Mannschaft, aber man hat halt zweimal so eklatante Fehler gemacht, die dir so einfach nicht passieren dürfen. Und das wäre so ein bisschen das, also nie laufen zwei Spiele genau gleich, das wissen wir alle. Aber das wäre trotzdem was, was mir aus Hannover sich so ein bisschen, ähm, ja Sorgen machen würde. Und ich sag's gerne nochmal, natürlich ist bei ihnen dann doch der Druck am größten, ne? Also das ist auch vom Namen her, ne?
Das definitiv.
Anders als bei der SVW, als einem Paderborn, ist natürlich da jetzt schon so, dass alle drauf gucken und denken so, ja, aber dann, also macht jetzt auch so. Und da bin ich jetzt mal sehr gespannt. Also es wird ein generell nächste Woche Sonntag 15.30. Also ich sag mal so, ich glaube, das wird eine witzige Konferenz. Ich wünsche, ich kriege da zum Glück gar nichts von mit, wenn ich nicht im Stadion stehen werde. Aber das, also ich weiß auch nicht, ob das gesünder für meinen Blutdruck ist oder schlechter. Das wird sich noch heraus. Also das finden wir noch heraus nächste Woche. Aber ja, also ich würde, Pader, äh Paderborn, sage ich schon, Hannover, wenn wir so ein kleines Power-Ranking erstellen wollen, ja, so einen, so einen Mittelfeldplatz geben, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, was sagt das über eine Mannschaft für den letzten Spieltag aus, wenn man ihr den kompletten Spiel, äh komplette Saison, fehlenden Killer-Instinkt unterstellt? Was macht sie dann im letzten Spieltag damit? Weißt du? Also und das ist ja auch etwas, was man schon, was ja schon auch Christian Tietz so ein bisschen umgibt, bei allem Lob für seinen Fußball, dass es er es oft dann nicht hinbekommt, seine Mannschaften auch konstant punkten zu lassen. Letztes Jahr hatte er natürlich, da darf man ihm keinen Strick draus drehen, weil es war Magdeburg. Also es wäre eine völlig krasse Überraschung gewesen, wenn man hochgegangen wäre. Aber wie Magdeburg auseinandergekrübelt ist, in der letzten Saisonphase, mal sehen, ob er sich auch selbst davon lösen kann. Denn darum wird es jetzt gehen. Du musst eigentlich nur in die Köpfe deiner Spieler kommen. Dann ist Hannover gut genug, um Nürnberg zu schlagen und dann wahrscheinlich dritter zu werden, vielleicht sogar zweiter zu werden. Sie hätten es insgesamt über den Saisonverlauf verdient. Aber das ist alles egal. Es ist ein Spiel. Und da bin ich gespannt, ob er und seine Mannschaft die Coolness bewahren können. Und dementsprechend hat Hannover eher was zu verlieren, irgendwie, wie ich finde. Der SC Paderborn hingegen hat eher jetzt was zu gewinnen, wenn man so möchte. Je nachdem, wie man die emotionale Lage auffassen möchte. Denn insgesamt haben sie zuletzt relativ viel verloren. Man kann sagen, dem SC Paderborn geht die Luft aus. Man hat aus den letzten vier Spielen nur zwei Punkte geholt, steht jetzt mit ebenfalls 59 Punkten, aber eben mit einem Torverhältnis von plus 12. Also um vier Tore schlechteres Torverhältnis als Hannover steht man auf Platz vier. Es sah teilweise sehr viel besser aus, aber natürlich vor allem dieses 1 zu 5 gegen Elbersberg war ein richtiger Schlag in die Magengrube. Und man muss ja auch sagen, das Restprogramm von Paderborn hat es ein wenig von den Dächern schreien lassen, dass es eventuell auch schwierig wird. Denn man hat einen Punkt gegen Hannover geholt, man hat gegen Schalke verloren, obwohl man da ja noch geführt hatte. Dann dieses 1 zu 5 gegen Elbersberg. Und ich würde sogar behaupten, all diese Spiele, das kann passieren. Aus der Selbstwahrnehmung und der Stärke eines SC Paderborn kannst du sagen, das kann passieren. Was einen richtig ärgern dürfte und auch getan hat, das hat man dann in den Bildern danach gesehen, war jetzt das 2 zu 2 gegen den KSC. Denn man muss sagen, auch dieses Spiel steht so ein bisschen dafür, was Paderborn in den letzten Wochen umgibt. Man hat so ein bisschen an Schärfe verloren. Defensiv passieren einem sehr naive Fehler. Wie man gegen den KSC Gegentore hergeschenkt hat, war wirklich, wirklich nicht gut. Also da hat man sich wirklich dämlich angestellt. Und zeitgleich hat man eben auch vorne entweder den letzten Pass vermissen lassen oder die Präzision im Abschluss. Denn die Struktur, die hat gestimmt in dem Spiel und die hat ganz oft gestimmt. Aber du hattest dann einfach nicht mehr, da sind wir wieder bei dem Punkt, die Coolness, die Souveränität, um das defensiv wie offensiv halt runterzurocken. Dieses 2 zu 2 gegen den KSC darf dir eigentlich nicht passieren. Und man hat den Frust allen auch angemerkt. Da gab es auch kleine Rudelbildung nach Abpfiff. Ralf Kettemann hat sich mit einem, ich weiß nicht, wer es genau war, ich kannte die Person nicht aus dem Betreuerstab vom KSC. Die hatten sich gut in den Haaren, mussten getrennt werden. Da siehst du ja, dass es jetzt einfach im Kopf angekommen ist. Und bei allem Understatement, wenn du so weit kommst in einer Saison, willst du natürlich aufsteigen. Aber dann darfst du dir Spiele gegen den KSC nicht erlauben. Das war in der Struktur in Ordnung. Ich fand, da war ein schönes Szenen dabei. Das eine Tor, wo man das Zentrum öffnet, boah, war das schön gespielt. Aber wie man dann wiederum kurz danach selber keinen mehr im 6er-Raum hat und Paderborn, äh, Paderborn, sag ich schon, KSC, einfach spazieren darf zum Tor, das ist dann wiederum einigermaßen irre. Da zeigt sich dann vielleicht auch im Saisonverlauf irgendwann die fehlende Breite im Kader solch eine Mannschaft, dass du irgendwann, ne, die Spiele werden schwerer, die Beine werden schwerer. Du kannst halt, wenn ein Castaneda rausgeht, vielleicht nicht genauso nachlegen. Am Ende ist das Ergebnis, dass Paderborn jetzt der Herausforderer ist von den 3 auf Platz 4. Man spielt auswärts in Darmstadt, die sich ordentlich aus der Saison verabschieden wollen und natürlich die größte Qualität all dieser Gegner jetzt haben im Vergleich zu Münster und Nürnberg. Also du hast jetzt auch das schwerste Spiel, weil auswärts, weil Darmstadt. Ja, ich tue mich schwer. Ich glaube, am Ende könnte Paderborn tatsächlich da einfach vom Tableau gerutscht sein. Und das wäre bitter, weil sie über weite Phasen der Saison, sie waren ja sogar mal relativ lange Erster, da darf man sich auch schon erinnern. Aber jetzt gerade habe ich das Gefühl, die wirken nervös.
Ich würde den einen Punkt widersprechen. Ich würde schon sagen, dass das 1 zu 5 gegen Elbersberg dir so auch nicht passieren darf. Also, wenn du ihn vermerkst, einfach weil, ich meine, davon reden wir jetzt seit 4 Wochen, dass es sich damals schon abgezeichnet hat, dass so Torverhältnismäßig, da könnte sich schon noch was tun. Und dann verlierst du ja nicht nur gegen irgendwen, sondern auch gegen eine direkte Konkurrenz. Also nicht nur machst du eben diese Lücke auf im Torverhältnis, sondern gibst die Tore natürlich auch deinem direkten Konkurrenten, der auch aus dem Grund jetzt eben zwar punktgleich mit dir ist, aber eben ein deutlich besseres Torverhältnis hat, wo man, finde ich, in der Konzentration mit plus zehn durchaus schon sprechen kann. Also mehr als. Und man muss auch sagen, es gab zwischendurch diese Spiele gegen Braunschweig und Bielefeld, wo man dann auch dachte, okay, warum lassen sie da jetzt Punkte? Ja, dann hat man gegen Dresden und Fürth und Magdeburg gewonnen. Aber da muss man, wenn man was kritisieren will, das ist natürlich auch hier immer noch mecker auf hohem Niveau, ist, dass man da auch keine richtige Konstanz reingebracht hat in solche Duellen, wo du spielerisch vielleicht eigentlich schon das bessere Team warst. Aber ich gehe sonst mit deiner Analyse auch zum KSC-Spiel mit. Also davon habe ich natürlich jetzt live weniger gesehen. Aber ja, und Darmstadt per se natürlich schon besser platziert als Nürnberg und Münster. Gleichzeitig muss man sagen, die haben auch nicht wahnsinnig über– also da merkst du auch, das haben wir auch in der Gruppe besprochen, da ist die Puste raus, Pfeiffer, der verletzt raus musste, ich glaube Margits hat den noch verletzt raus musste. Und da merkst du dann auch, Liedberg, der eben den Elfmeter verschießt, weil der sich natürlich den auch nimmt, weil es für den natürlich noch so um Tore, also einfach da in der Gesamtwertung geht. Muss man schon sagen, das war dann so ein bisschen dröger auch hinten raus, das könnte halt Paderborns– also da wird halt die Frage dann sein im direkten Duell, wer schafft es denn hier, die Tugenden, die sie über weite Strecken der Saison auf den Platz gebracht hat, noch mal besser umzusetzen. Und da muss man einfach sagen, dass Darmstadt einfach ein bisschen im Nachteil aufgrund der personellen Sorgen, die Paderborn eventuell so der nächste Woche nicht hat und weil es für Paderborn– aber gleichzeitig eben auch Darmstadt kann halt, ich sag mal befreit ausspielen und will natürlich zum Ende raus seine Fans mit einer ja immer noch sehr guten Heimbilanz sicherlich auch in die Sommerpause verschieben. Also das einfach nur noch abzuründen. Aber ich, also mich hat echt dieses, das Schalke-Spiel danach, auch die Ansagen, die ich es danach gab, haben wir hier auch besprochen, die waren sehr offensiv noch formuliert. Und wie du es dann, irgendwie dann doch, und da muss man glaube ich den Mentalitätsaspekt mit reinbringen, wie du es dann, wie du dann so untergehst in Elbersberg und dann dieses Spiel gegen KSC, da merkt man dann vielleicht doch, das ist auch noch ein relativ junger Kader einfach.
Das wollte ich gerade sagen. Du hast echt, also bis auf Felix Götze und Sven Michel, hast du quasi keine erfahreneren Führungsspieler. Ja, Rafael Obermeier, aber der ist jetzt auch verletzt. Also der hat ja nachher das sehen andere ist, richtig ekelige Nummer. Das heißt, der ist jetzt auch raus. Aber sonst hast du da keine erfahreneren Spieler drin. Zumal Sven Michel wirklich ja auch eher dann für 10, 15 Minuten dir noch was gibt und länger nicht auf dem Feld steht. Jetzt sehe ich gerade, dass Stefan Tigges auch gelb-rot gesperrt fehlen wird im letzten Spiel. Also da fehlt dir zumindest– ich sage nicht, dass Stefan Tigges der große Unterschiedspieler ist, aber er war es in der Saison de facto teilweise. Es gab Spiele, in denen ging spielerisch gar nichts. Und dann hast du Stefan Tigges eingewechselt, der in der Luft immer was produzieren kann. Also die Waffe ist dir zumindest am letzten Spieltag genommen. Oh, und Felix Götze? Ach nee, Rotsperrin D. Vierbrucker zum Glück. Ich dachte, ich habe was nicht mitbekommen. Der hat euch jetzt nicht rot gesehen. Gut, also das ist kein Faktor. Aber ich möchte unterschreiben, dir fehlen teilweise auch die erfahrenen Führungsspieler, die in so einer Situation die Coolness bewahren. Das ist definitiv so. Und deswegen muss man gefühlt hinter allen ein Fragezeichen setzen. Ich würde Elversberg schon, weil ich mir das sehr gut erklären kann, wie diese Niederlage gegen Düsseldorf zustande kommt, mache ich mir um die, die wenigsten Sorgen und glaube tatsächlich, dass Elversberg das Ding machen wird. Also wenn du mich jetzt nach dem Bauchgefühl fragst, sage ich, die Tabelle bleibt so, wie sie ist. Also Elversberg kommt durch, Hannover, Relegation, Paderborn, dann auf Platz 4, Herrscher vorbei. Vielleicht sogar alle mit derselben Punktzahl. Alle gewinnen ihre Spiele, das kann ich mir alles vorstellen. Aber stand jetzt, habe ich das Gefühl, Paderborn, es gab auch diese Spiele, die sie gewonnen haben, die aber dann auch nicht so richtig gut waren. Das Dresden-Spiel zum Beispiel, es muss Dresden gewinnen eigentlich. Waren besser. Das summiert sich gerade ganz schön auf, dass ich mir vorstellen kann, dass es am letzten Spieltag ganz schön knirschen wird bei denen.
Und man muss dann ja auch sagen, Kevin mag mit dir widersprechen oder zustimmen. Ich glaube, für die Entwicklung des SCP-Unterkettemann ist ein Liga-Verbleib tatsächlich das Bessere. Also das will da jetzt niemand hören und das verstehe ich auch total. Also bitte nicht falsch verstehen. Ich komme jetzt um die Ecke und sage hier, seid ihr zufrieden mit dem, was ihr habt? Aber ich glaube, tatsächlich für die Entwicklung, weil es einfach so ein junger Kader ist und ein junger Trainer ist, so ist es glaube ich per se für die Entwicklung sowohl für Trainer als auch Spieler, weil wir wissen, wie sowas dann halt auch in der Bundesliga laufen kann. Und gerade der SC Paderborn weiß das auch, aus der Historie hinaus. Vielleicht tut es dann in der Merve aufzusteigen und du gehst dann vielleicht klanglos wieder runter, weil ich sehe da tatsächlich das Fundament. Da ist nochmal das Wort in der Bundesliga tatsächlich noch nicht so geschaffen, wie es bei einem Heidenheim beispielsweise der Fall war oder so. Und da weiß ich nicht, ob du dir am Ende nicht mehr kaputt machst, weil Paderborn hat das dann auch schon mal, dass man dann eben einmal auch komplett durchgereicht wurde. Es gab ja immer diese Zeit, entweder 2. oder 18. Tag. Das wäre dann halt was, wo ich gut, genau das gleiche kann man natürlich in Teilen natürlich auch auf Elversberg und Hannover, obwohl ich Hannover einfach vom Standort her nochmal etwas andere, eine andere Zeugnis ausstellen würde. Aber das gilt natürlich genauso auch für Elversberg, weil Elversberg ja einfach viel mit Leihspielern arbeitet, weil da natürlich seitdem Oleburg weg ist, da ist natürlich auch die Frage, wie stellt man sich jetzt auf? Wie geht es da weiter? Muss man glaube ich sagen, jetzt wirklich rein emotionslos gesehen, wäre es für beide Vereine gar nicht mal so schlimm, wenn man vielleicht sagt, okay, wir gehen mit dem Ziel, Bundesliga-Ausstieg in die nächste Saison, weil wir kommen aus einer Position heraus, wo wir uns das erlauben können. Aber man auch sagen kann, wir hätten dann trotzdem glaube ich gegenüber sehr, sehr vielen Vereinen auch einen Vorteil.
Absolut, absolut. Gut, genug dem Blick nach oben gerichtet. Wir gucken nach unten und wir gucken als auch da tabellarisch geordnet und beginnen damit mit dem ersten FC Magdeburg, der so gut wie gerettet scheint, es aber eben einfach noch nicht ist, Eva.
Genau, es ist Platz 12, es sind 39 Punkte, 52 zu 57 Tore, 12 Siege, 3 Unentschieden und 18 Niederlagen. Der Grund, warum man vielleicht Magdeburg auch nicht nur tabellarisch, sondern das schiebe ich schon mal vor, auch in der Gesamtkonstellation, einfach gerade, ich sag mal, die Pole-Position für den Klassenherhalt so ein bisschen einräumt, ist einfach auch die Formkurve in den letzten Spielen, da ist man auf Platz 4. Man hat, was eben andere Vereine nicht geschafft haben, gerade ist sehr, sehr gut geschafft, die direkten Duellen da unten drin zu gewinnen. Also man konnte gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf gewinnen, man hat als es für die noch auch um was ging, gegen Bochum und gegen Münster gewonnen, zwischendurch zwar mal Niederlagen gegen Paderborn und Nürnberg drin, aber jetzt zuletzt eben auch die Serie gegen Hertha und eben auch schon das gerettete Kiel, was ja schon letzte Woche, nicht letzte Saison, feststand. Also man hat es eben geschafft, sich auch zwischenzeitlich, fand ich, aus einer Position, wo man wieder dachte so, da rutschen sie doch wieder rein, da eben genau zum richtigen Zeitpunkt, zu einem guten Schlussspurt anzusetzen. Wie gesagt, 3-1-Sieg gegen Kiel am Wochenende, da konnte man dann doch auch, glaube ich, den Kielern so ein bisschen, dass da nicht mehr die letzten 100 Prozent gegangen worden sind. Und Marc, ich würde tatsächlich sagen, auch wenn es– ich mache den Call jetzt einfach schon mal– ich glaube, der 1. FCM, der bleibt noch eine weitere Saison in der 2. Liga. Und ich glaube, nach dem Saisonverlauf kann man das fast sogar schon als kleines Wunder bezeichnen.
Ey, da geben wir uns die Klinke in die Hand. Ich sehe es genauso. Ich glaube auch, dass Magdeburg gerettet ist. Auch, weil man die Heimschwäche in den Griff bekommen hat zuletzt. Man hat die letzten drei Heimspiele allesamt gewonnen. Gegen Hertha, gegen Düsseldorf, gegen Bochum. In der Zeit übrigens auch nur ein Gegentreffer kassiert. Magdeburg untypisch. Also gepaart mit dem, was du gesagt hast, glaube ich, dass sie gerettet sind. Man muss nämlich auch sagen, also klar, wir können uns jetzt immer an die Punkte, die zu Platz 16, 17 ragen, klammern. Wir können aber auch sagen, dazwischen stehen ja so viele Mannschaften. Also wie viel muss passieren, dass wenn Magdeburg, selbst wenn Magdeburg verliert, wie viel muss passieren, dass sie wirklich noch auf den Relegationsrang, das ist ja das höchste der Gefühle, noch durchgereicht werden? Das halte ich für einfach sehr unwahrscheinlich. Ich glaube, das erledigt sich eh, weil sie gegen Lautern sehr gute Chancen haben, Punkte zu holen. So, Lautern ist ja, also, das ist ein ganz eigenes Thema und ein Thema für einen Saisonrückblick. Diese Lautern-Saison, mit denen kann es ja auch in keiner Hinsicht rechnen. Wir reden ja gleich noch ein bisschen drüber im Bielefeld-Segment. Ja, es ist so eine Misch-, es ist so ganz, es ist eine verrückte Welt. Und dann auf der einen Seite sage ich auch, es ist ein Wunder irgendwo, dass Magdeburg sich rettet, es ist aber absolut verdient. Das finde ich stimmt zeitgleich beides. Ich finde, selbst die Spiele unter Markus Fiedler, die ja im Ergebnis katastrophal waren, waren nicht so richtig schlecht. Da hat man auch schon was gesehen, aber dann hat man sich irgendwann, ich fand es auch verständlich, aus Ergebnisgründen musste man sagen, wir müssen das abbrechen, so. Aber man hat danach mit Patrick Sander, der alten Legende, ja schon wieder diesen alten Stil ein Stück weit aufleben lassen. Ab und zu, vor allem im Saison-Endspurt, ist man ein bisschen konservativer in den Spielen ansetzen geworden. Das hat auch manchmal gar nicht so gut funktioniert. Also da wird uns Thomas zustimmen, dass dieses 0 zu 1 gegen Nürnberg fast selbst gemacht war, wenn man da so ein bisschen in den Stärken der Mannschaft vorbeigecoacht hat. Aber insgesamt wirkt das stimmig. Diese Mannschaft funktioniert auch da, glaube ich. Also wir wissen ja, dass es im Sommer einen Riesenumbruch bei Magdeburg geben wird, auch weil es eine neue sportliche Führung gibt. Da laufen Verträge aus. Man möchte mehr auf eine eigene Jugend setzen und so weiter. Da passiert viel. Und es ist eher die Frage, in welcher Liga passiert das? Jetzt würde ich sagen, haben wir ansatzweise die Gewissheit, es passiert in Liga 2. Das freut mich auch. Also Ostvereine in der 2. Liga dürfen gerne vertreten sein, das tut dem Gesamtbild der Liga gut. Magdeburg hat viele Fans, bringt viel mit. Das ist ein Gewinn für diese Liga. Und wie gesagt, auch da, die waren in fast keinem Spiel wirklich schlecht. Und die Spiele, die sie verloren haben, waren teilweise absolute Freak-Spiele. Ich erinnere mich am Anfang der Saison an Spiele, das konnte man nicht glauben, dass sie da den Ball nicht unterbekommen haben. Das war in der Rückrunde teilweise auch so, wie du sagst, es gab diese Phase so, ja, Anfang der Rückrunde bis zur Mitte der Rückrunde war es wirklich schlimm von den Ergebnissen her. Aber man wird sich retten, das ist verdient. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, wie sich dann Magdeburg auch wahrscheinlich ja mit einem neuen Trainer, also ich nehme nicht an, dass Patrick Sander das weitermacht, neu aufstellen wird. Das wird richtig spannend, werden sie auch ihren offensiven Stil beibehalten, werden sie konservativer, weil das ist ja auch alles sehr noch Teats geprägt. Bin ich gespannt. Also, aber trotzdem sage ich auch hier, man darf wirklich noch nicht beglückwünschen, dann öffnet man wirklich, ich bin nicht abergläubig, aber dann öffnet man wirklich Tür und Tor für alles Mögliche. Aber ich bin sehr positiv gestimmt, dass Magdeburg sich am Ende retten wird. Wenn du jetzt nichts weiter zu dem FCM hast.
Nur einen Einwand, Baris Atik, der hatte ja diese direkte Ecke noch verwandelt. Und sehr lange war Magdeburg, glaube ich, einer der schlechtesten Mannschaften auch nach Standards. Und dann eine direkte Ecke verwandeln. Respekt.
Sie haben halt mit ihm und Zukowski diese X-Faktoren, die sie auch in der Liga halten werden.
Ja, aber sonst habe ich dieses Wochenende, glaube ich, direkte Ecke verwandeln nur von Larissa Müller beim Spiel Bremen gegen Kalsas Jena gesehen. Auch sehr sicher. Aber ja, man muss was sagen. Baris Atik hat nach dem Spiel auch gesagt, ganz ehrlich für mich mental auch nicht ganz einfach. Ich glaube, Baris Atik ist vom Mensch her jemand, der scheidet so ein bisschen die Geister. Also manchmal…
Schon ein Giftswerk auf dem Feld, ja.
Genau. Also ich glaube, manchmal wird es ihm in der Außenerstellung auch gut tun, wenn er, ich sag mal, so ein bisschen tatsächlich mehr so seine gefühlvolle Seite, im Sinne von nicht die aggressive Seite zeigt. Weil eigentlich ist es ja auch wirklich eine sehr, sehr prägende Person bei Magdeburg, aber macht es manchmal… Also ich hatte zwischendurch das Gefühl, der war ja schneller dabei, mit dem Finger auf andere zu zeigen, wo er selber natürlich auch seine Leistungen nicht abgerufen hat immer.
Stimmt, ja.
Aber wie gesagt, den Rest hast du sonst schon angesprochen, aber er hat das eben nach dem Spiel gegen Kiel eben nochmal angesprochen.
Und das kann man ja auch verstehen. Der liebt diesen Verein, der ist da verwurzelt, dann verfrustet man und dann verkrampft man und so weiter. Aber auch er, muss man sagen, hat sich in der Saison wieder extremst gesteigert und war eben mit Zukofsky zusammen letztendlich der entscheidende Faktor dafür, dass Magdeburg sehr wahrscheinlich die Klasse halten wird. Und dann würde ich sagen, kommen wir zum nächsten Ostverein, der sehr wahrscheinlich die Klasse halten wird, mit noch ein paar Abzügen in der B-Note. Aber auch da sieht es ganz gut aus. Dynamo Dresden. Mit 38 Punkten steht man auf Rang 12. Rang 12, ist richtig, ne?
13.
13, siehste. Das war zwischenzeitlich Rang 12 oder so. Gut, Rang 13. Das sind 2 Zähler auf den Relegationsrang und 4 auf Platz 17. Also auch da steht schon mal fest, dass der direkte Abstieg nicht mehr möglich ist. Man kann allerhöchstens noch auf den Relegationsrang landen. Auch da, würde ich sagen, nach der Hinrunde hätte man das unterschrieben. Aber Stand jetzt sieht es eben noch besser aus. Man hat jetzt 2 Niederlagen und 3 Siege in den letzten 5 Spielen geholt und am 33. Spieltag trotz einer sehr bemühten Leistung etwas unglücklich mit 1 zu 2 gegen Braunschweig verloren. Ich habe das Spiel in kompletter Länge gesehen. Werde jetzt versuchen, Braunschweig nicht zu sehr mit zu verhandeln. Aber ich möchte letztendlich auch da abgekürzt sagen, dieses Spiel bekräftigt nochmal, dass man sich keine Sorgen um Dresden machen sollte. Die haben ein Heimspiel gegen Holstein Kiel. Auch da wird Druck drauf sein, um Gottes Willen. Und Kiel kann in dem Sinne Befreiheit auch spielen. Aber die haben jetzt auch ein bisschen losgelassen bei dem Spiel. Mal gucken, ob ihn das Walter nochmal erlaubt. Aber dieses Spiel gegen Braunschweig, das ist ein ganz verrücktes Spiel gewesen. Also erstmal war da richtig Druck auf den Kessel. Und das hat als Außenstehender dadurch irgendwie auch Spaß gemacht. Aber ich kann verstehen, dass das für alle Beteiligten, Grüße an Anna, irre Nerven aufreibend war. Ich kann für jeden Spielausgang Argumente finden im Spiel. So ein Spiel ist das. Ich finde, man kann Argumente dafür finden, warum Braunschweig dieses Spiel gewinnt und das irgendwie okay ist. Es hätte definitiv ein Unentschieden sein können. Und wenn man sich die reine Chancenanzahl anguckt, kann man sogar sagen, ey, wenn Dresden das gewinnt, hätte sich Braunschweig auch nicht völlig beschweren dürfen. Das Ding ist nur, dass Dresden sehr lange Spielkontrolle hatte, aber es hat gegen sehr disziplinierte Braunschweiger nicht geschafft, ein Schlüssel zu finden. Also diese völlige Wucht, die kam erst zum Ende. Und man darf auch nicht unterschätzen, bei diesem Ex-Back-to-Goals, wenn man sich den anguckt, da kommen natürlich auch wieder 0,77 durch den Elfmeter, den Stefan Kutschke letztendlich nicht verwandelt. Aber wenig später macht er dann ja den Kopfball rein zum 1-2. Also macht er doch noch sein erstes Saisontor in seiner letzten Saison für Dynamo. Das kann man auch sagen. Karriereende wird aber Dynamo halten bleiben. Keine weiteren Kommentare dazu. Also man hat erst, als man wirklich alles nach vorne geworfen hat und maximal das Risiko gegangen ist, hatte man die richtigen Chancen. Zwischenzeitlich war Ron Taubman trotzdem ein, zwei Mal da. Das kann man schon sagen. Aber die Riesenchance war nicht da. Aber zeitgleich fand ich nicht, dass Dresden sich jetzt auch hat verrückt machen lassen. Die wollten schon ihr Stil durchziehen. Das war kalkuliertes Risiko zum Ende hin. Man hat es immer weiter erhöht. Wenn dann vielleicht auch das 1 zu 3 gefallen wäre, dann wäre das so gewesen. Aber in der Situation spielst du natürlich nach vorne. Ich glaube auch da, dass Dresden sehr wahrscheinlich die Klasse halten wird. Das ist aufgrund dieser extrem guten Rückrunde, wie ich finde, und dem Mut, den man im Winter hatte, auch verdient dann. Man hat die richtigen Dinge erkannt, hat personell nachjustiert. Genau diese Spieler mit Bobzin und Co. haben den Unterschied auch gemacht. Keller in der Innenverteidigung ist dann natürlich auch zu nennen. Dieses Spiel ist ein sehr gebrauchter Tag irgendwie auch für die gewesen. Ich finde schon, dass Braunschweig aufgrund der Art und Weise, wie sie das Spiel angehen wollten, durchaus als verdienter Sieger vom Platz gegangen sind. Aber ich glaube, Dresden hält die Klasse. Das ist dann am Ende vielleicht mit Nervenkitzel verbunden. Natürlich kann auch was passieren. Da sind dann wie gesagt nur noch drei Teams, die gegen sie spielen müssen mit Braunschweig, Düsseldorf und Bielefeld. Aber auch das muss erst mal passieren. Und wie gesagt, Dresden hat ja auch alles in der eigenen Hand.
Ja, und halt ein ausgeglichenes Torverhältnis. Also als einzige da unten drin, eben keine negativ. Ich würde tatsächlich noch ein bisschen widersprechen, weil ja, Dresden hatte Spielkontrolle, aber ich finde, du konntest eben schon von Anfang an so ein bisschen merken. Also ich habe es in der Konferenz geguckt, to be fair. Aber dass man schon irgendwie so ein bisschen wusste, ha, Braunschweig muss schon mehr machen. Und ich fand dann schon, dass gerade nach dem 1-0, dass die Reaktion dann noch nicht so ganz da war. Also wirklich erst mit dem zweiten Gegentor. Und ich fand da fast ironisch, vom Spielverlauf her und von dem, was Dresden investiert hat, fast tatsächlich dann parallel zur Hinrunde. Weil auch in der Hinrunde hatten wir immer wieder Spiele, wo wir– Dresden war ja nie richtig, richtig schlecht. Wir haben da einfach immer nur gesagt, es fehlt einfach die Zweiliga-Qualität im Kader. Und wenn wir da mal gucken, das Spiel gegen Braunschweig in der Hinrunde, hat man eben 2 zu 3 verloren, nach 2 zu 0 Führung von Braunschweig. Das Spiel gegen Kiel hat man auch verloren. Das wäre so ein bisschen was, ich unterschreibe das, dass ich auch glaube, dass sie am Ende in der Liga bleiben. Einfach aufgrund der Umstände. Aber ich fand jetzt nicht, dass man sagen konnte, man geht aus diesem Spiel raus und sagt so, ja gut, das war dann einfach nur Pech bei Dresden. Also ich fand das schon…
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Also nicht nur Pech, sondern ich fand nämlich schon, dass ich finde am Ende des Tages trotzdem in dem Spiel weniger Argumente, die für einen Dresden-Sieg gesprochen hätten. Also und wir wissen, Braunschweig, die sind momentan einfach nur auf Kurs. Wir brauchen den Sieg, der Rest ist uns gerade relativ wumpe. So, ne, hat Anna ja auch schon gesagt, also man kann, der Sieg gegen Lautern von Braunschweig war so eine Kategorie, naja, Arbeit, für Fußballspielen. Aber ja, also das fand ich so ein bisschen… Also da hat man sich selber so ein bisschen ins Ausgespielt zwischendurch in der Partie, dass man kann dann natürlich auch darüber diskutieren, also ich bin auch team, kein Kommentar bei Stefan Kutschke sonst, ob das auch ehrlich gesagt, also dafür geht es für Dynamo noch um zu viel, als dass man Kutschke dann da so reinbringt und ja klar, er macht hinter das 2-1, aber der kann halt auch in beide Richtungen ausschlagen als Pendel, ja, also…
Ja gut, macht den Elfmeter nicht… Mich hat es auch gewundert, dass eben nicht da ferner eingewechselt wurde. Ich glaube, dann geht es bei Kutschke wirklich um… Also egal, was man von diesem Menschen hält, der hat ja eine Führungsstärke in diesem Kader. Und dann geht es eher glaube ich darum, jemanden auf Sage zu schicken, der sich da, wie sagt man so schön, nichts scheißt und allein das soll dann auf die Kollegen abfärben. Tatsächlich finde ich den Punkt ganz gut, was du gesagt hast mit dem Vergleich zur Hinrunde und da kann man ja eben oft daher zu sagen, da fehlt die Qualität. Das passt insofern zu diesem Spiel, weil Julian Pauli in der Innenverteidigung gefehlt hatte und dann hat sich auch noch Thomas Keller in der 1. Halbzeit so verletzt, dass dann Claudio Kammerknecht reinkam. Fünf Minuten später, also fünf Minuten nach Wiedernfeld, fällt er dann noch das 2 zu 0. Also da sind wir dann auch bei teilweise einem endigen Spieler in der Defensive vor allem gefehlt und das merkst du diesem Kader sofort an, weil der zweite Anzug halt nicht so gut ist. Also das ist dann vielleicht die Brücke, die man schlagen kann. Apropos Brücke schlagen, ich würde fast sagen, wenn wir schon in dem Quartier sind, dann gehen wir doch über, weil sonst wird das irgendwie so ein wenig flüssiger Übergang. Dann sind wir nicht mehr Eintracht Braunschweig und ich würde das unterschreiben, was du sagst, dass es jetzt nicht nur Pech war bei Dresden. Ich fand halt nur Dresden nicht wirklich schlecht. Ich fand halt Braunschweig irgendwie in ihrer Spielanlage nur noch überzeugender, denn man hat sich ja schon für Lars Kornetka entschieden, weil der auch irgendwie etwas mit Ball entwickeln soll und auch ein bisschen besser und schöner und stringenter spielen lassen soll. Alte Zahneiner Backhaus. Das war ja schon eines der Ziele. Aber du bist natürlich irgendwann in einer Saison an dem Punkt. Du hast es eben erwähnt. Anna hat es erwähnt. Punkte, Punkte, Punkte, Punkte. Und in dem Spiel, finde ich, hat Lars Kornetka bewiesen, dass der Gegendenball auch richtig gut kann. Also das war ein Spiel, wo ich das Gefühl hatte, das muss man sehr viel an ihm festmachen. Der hat zum einen den Move gebracht, fünf neue zu bringen. Fünf neue Spieler hat vor dem Spiel gesagt, er möchte eine neue Energie und Leichtigkeit reinbringen. Und ich finde, ein Schlüsselspieler in dem Sinne war Kaufmann. Fabio Kaufmann, die alte Braunschweig-Legende, der seit einem Jahr, glaube ich, hat der Kommentator gesagt, nicht mehr in der Startelf stand und in der Saison keine Rolle gespielt hat. Da sind wir mal ehrlich, also er kam ab und zu als, er kam vorher 15 Mal rein als Einwechsespieler. Und den hat er von Anfang an gebracht und weil er wusste, wir brauchen jetzt Jungs, die kennen diesen Abschießkampf. Und in diesem Spiel hat sich dann eine Achse von Spielern herausgebildet, die einfach sich, denen war das so alles egal. Und die haben diesen Druck so getrotzt und diese Truppe so zusammengehalten und es war die Achse Hoffmann im Tor, Lino Tempelmann im Mittelfeld und dann eben Fabio Kaufmann auf der Außenbahn mit deren Erfahrung auch im Abstiegskampf. Die haben das ja auch schon mit Braunschweig ein, zwei Mal mitgemacht, haben die dieses sehr Aufopferungs- und disziplinierte Spiel gegen den Ball angeführt. Braunschweig war kantig, die waren eklig, die haben den Fuß draufgehalten, die haben dadurch auch Dynamos Spielfluss immer wieder zerstört, haben aber auch im 4-4-2 gegen den Ball die Ketten super eng gemacht. Also Dynamo hatte es sehr schwer. Das war jetzt nicht nur eben dieses Heiner Backhaus. Wir müssen ekliger sein, sondern es war auch intelligent im Spiel gegen den Ball. Ich fand, man hat es geschafft, vor allem in der ersten Halbzeit, Dynamo das eigene Spiel aufzudrücken. Und ja, dann lebt das auch ein Stück weit von Glück, dass man dann diese beiden Tore macht, denn man hat ja nicht viel produziert. Dann gilt es, in diesen Momenten da zu sein. Am ersten Tor war ja Tempelmann zum Beispiel beteiligt, weil er diesen Ball da ist, in den 16er führt. Und dann ist Flick beim zweiten Ball da, zack, 1-0. Und beim 2-0 ist es dann ja Fabio Kaufmann, der die Flanke schlägt in die Mitte. Also dann sind diese Spieler da, und das sind halt Spieler, die wissen aus den letzten Jahren, wir brauchen diesen eingeheulene Moment, und dann müssen wir da sein, und das waren sie. Deswegen fand ich, das war für den Zustand von Braunschweig und für die Situation in der Tabelle und so weiter, war das ein blitzsauberes Heimspiel. Das wird sich nicht so angefühlt haben, besonders nach dem 2-1 Gegentreffer. Wie gesagt, du hättest auch Argumente für eine Punkteteilung definitiv finden können. Aber du hast dieses Spiel, du hast es erzwungen. Natürlich hält Ron Torbenhoffmann in diesem Spiel einen Elfmeter. Natürlich ist der da. Also das hat irgendwie in dieses Spiel gepasst, und ich fand's imponierend, wie Braunschweig aufgetreten ist. Das hat man diese Saison nicht so oft gesehen, weil es eine Mischung aus Wille und Cleverness war. Das fehlte oft. Und deswegen ist das ein Heimsieg, der irgendwie in Ordnung geht. Und letztendlich dazu führen könnte, dass man in der Liga bleibt, zeigt gleich. Um das einmal einzubinden, muss man eben sagen, Braunschweig steht mit 37 Punkten auf Rang 14. Das ist ein einziger Punkt Abstand zum Religationsrang. Und du spielst jetzt auswärts auf Schalke, die sich gut verabschieden wollen zu Hause. Ja, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Also, das könnte schwierig sein.
Genau, und weil das ist nämlich mein einziges Problem, dass Braunschweig immer wieder diese Spiele zwischendurch drin hat, wo du eben siehst, was möglich ist unter Kornetka. Und dann hast du aber zwischendurch wieder diese Niederlage gegen Kiel drin. Ja?
Ja, ja, ja.
Und das wäre so was. Und dann, wie du schon sagst, Schalke. Also ich meine, man kann auch sagen, vielleicht haben sie auch genau deshalb letzte Woche auf Ibiza verbracht, weil sie gewusst haben, ja gut, wenn wir das jetzt die Woche vor dem Braunschweig-Spiel machen, dann gibt es irgendwie, da klopfen minimum 5 Vereine an und sagen, sag mal, habt ihr eigentlich irgendwie einen Schuss nicht mehr gehört? So. Und da muss man sagen, das ist halt, wo ich Braunschweig halt am Ende noch nicht diese vollständige Stabilität einräumen würde. Und Schalke ist halt einfach die beste Heimmannschaft der Liga. Und dafür ist einfach, hat man leider, also man teilt sich mit Düsseldorf eben, man muss sagen, immer noch ein katastrophales Torverhältnis von minus 17. Ja. Das heißt und klar, Bielefeld hat einen Punkt weniger, führt, würde ich jetzt mal mit minus 22 aus dieser Verrechnung ein bisschen rausnehmen. Aber wenn es beispielsweise am Ende darum geht, um Dresden, um Magdeburg und Bielefeld als die drei Konkurrenz, gut, Düsseldorf wird jetzt mal ausgenommen, dann stehst du da leider immer noch torverhältnismäßig am schlechtesten da. Und das liegt unter anderem natürlich dann auch daran, dass du eben, wie gesagt, keine vollständige Konstanz drin hattest, auch in den letzten Leistungen. Also Formtabelle Platz 12 ist halt wirklich das absolute Nirgendwo. Oder was ist denn so eine Formtabelle? Doch, Platz 10, Entschuldigung.
Am Ende stimmt halt irgendwie beides. Man will sich die Emotionswelt in Braunschweig nicht vorstellen ohne diesen Sieg. Stell dir mal vor, du verlierst das. Dann brennt es offensichtlich mehr, weil dann bist du punktgleich mit Firt. Und dann gehen die Lichter wirklich aus auf Schalke. So kannst du dir jetzt sagen, wir haben es in der eigenen Hand. Wenn wir was Verrücktes machen gegen Schalke, dann kann es das keiner nehmen. Und wir dürfen auch Selbstvertrauen aus diesem Spiel gegen Dresden nehmen. Zeitgleich stimmt absolut das, was du sagst. Es wird brutal schwer auf Schalke. Schalke will sich mit einem Sieg verabschieden, vor allen Dingen zu Hause. Die wollen sich nichts vorwerfen lassen. Und, ich weiß nicht, ob die das motiviert. Die wollen vielleicht auch noch die 70 Punkte erreichen. Mit einem Sieg wären sie bei 70 Punkten. Das sieht ja auch ganz nett aus. Also, ja, und ich glaube, die wollen sich eben auch nicht mit so einem schlechten Eindruck aus der Saison verabschieden, nachdem es schon gegen Nürnberg in die Binsen ging. Also, ich glaube nicht, dass Schalke dem was schenken wird. Und dann sind sie tatsächlich wieder von anderen abhängig. Und ich meine, wie gesagt, da reden wir rein theoretisch, je nachdem, wie es läuft, lass mal Fürth gewinnen und Braunschweig richtig auf den Deckel bekommen, dann sind eine Minus-5-Tor-Differenz auch nicht mehr so viel. Also, die haben sogar noch– Chancen klingen immer positiv– Risiken auf Platz 17. Also, ja, es stimmt beides.
Ja, aber man muss da natürlich trotzdem am Ende des Tages noch sagen, du hast es eben schon mal angesprochen, vielleicht dann doch am Ende des Tages ein leicht psychologischer Vorteil, dass die eben Abschiebskampf kennen. In vielen Konsolidationen da.
Ich glaube, nur so war dieser Sieg gegen Dresden möglich. Das war keine spielerische Kunst oder ähnliches. Ja.
Ich würde aber fast sagen, dann gehen wir zu einem Verein, der kennt Abschiebskampf ehrlich gesagt in den letzten Jahren noch nicht so.
Das ist richtig.
Aber hat es vielleicht zum richtigen Zeitpunkt geschafft, seinen Fighting Spirit da zurückzubekommen. Und das ist vor Tünnen und Düsseldorf. Nach dem Sieg heute gegen Elbersberg, wir haben es eben schon mal gesagt, ist es nämlich Platz 15, man ist punktgleich mit Eintracht Braunschweig. 33 zu 50 Tore, also die Offensive lässt trotzdem noch zu wünschen. 11 Siege, 4 Unentschieden, 18 Niederlagen stehen da zu Buche. Vorm Tabelle, da ist man auf Platz 11, weil man hatte eben drei Niederlagen drin, aber eben auch die zwei Siege zuletzt auch dabei, beziehungsweise unterbrochen von einer Liga-Lage zwischenzeitlich. Ja, es war, und das war auf Schalke, also da konnte man als Fortuna Düsseldorf ehrlich gesagt den jeglichen Reich nur verlieren. Marc, ich würde sagen, es ist etwas passiert, was wir nicht dachten, was noch passieren könnte.
Oha, jetzt bin ich aber gespannt.
Ja, nachdem Alex Ende kam und wir haben hier darüber diskutiert, ist das überhaupt der richtige Move? Also was, warum geht man mit Alex Ende? Passt das wirklich so? Dann hat man eben unter ihm das erste Spiel auch direkt wieder verloren, hat aber eben ganz, ganz wichtig den Dreier gegen Dynamo Dresden geholt und jetzt eben auch den Dreier gegen Elbersberg. Und ich würde vorsichtig sagen, dieser Trainerwechsel, der kam vielleicht doch noch zum richtigen Zeitpunkt. Und vielleicht hat man doch noch den richtigen Trainer für diesen Schlussspurt gefunden.
Ich verknallt mir einfach jedes Wortspiel, weil zu einfach. Ja, ich wusste, ich hatte keine klare Meinung zu diesem Trainerwechsel, weil vom Zeitpunkt her fand ich ihn total richtig an sich, weil man gesehen hat, boah, du befreist dich nicht mehr aus dieser Ergebniskrise. Wenn wir jetzt erstmal nur Ergebniskrise unter Markus anfangen. Und dann war für mich aber eben auch die Frage, ist das der richtige Trainer? Und zeitgleich bin ich eben auch nicht der Fan. Das hat ja vielleicht auch die Personalie Alois Schwarz in Münster gezeigt. Ich bin nicht der Fan, immer zu sagen, dann muss es der klassische Feuerwehrmann sein. Das berühmteste Beispiel dahingehend, ich sag mal im deutschen Fußball, ist glaube ich damals der Move gewesen, wo Hoffenheim Julian Nagelsmann zum Trainer gemacht hat. Und der dann mit offensiven Fußball, weil der Kader das damals hergab, das war ja noch, muss man sich vorstellen, Robert Bobby Firmino hat damals im Abschließkampf bei Hoffenheim gespielt. Und da hat er gesagt, na ja, wenn ich einen Bobby Firmino habe, dann sollte ich ja offensiv spielen. Und das hat ja Hoffenheim in der Klasse gehalten. Etwas jüngeres Beispiel ist Sebastian Hoeneß bei Stuttgart. Und, ich weiß gar nicht, war das damals sogar noch eine Personale von Misslint hat? Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher. Ich glaube, nee, kann, nee, natürlich nicht. Das kann gar nicht mehr hinkommen haben. Na ja, was ich sagen will ist, es gibt ja positiv Beispiele dahingehend, dass eine offensive Lösung, die zum Kader durchaus passt, mehr Ergebnisse verspricht, als dieser eher konservative Feuerwehrmann. Das ist irgendwie so dieser Ansatz, den man oft im Kopf hat. Abschließkampf, wir brauchen Sicherheit. Aber vielleicht braucht das die Mannschaft gar nicht. Und vielleicht musst du dann eher in die Stärken der Mannschaft reinspielen und die Stärke von Düsseldorf wird in dieser Saison nicht mehr die defensive werden. Das kannst du vergessen. Also mach doch aus deinem größten Faustpfand der Offensive das Maximale. Und dafür steht ja ein Alexander-Ende. Sicherlich mit einem sehr eigenen Weg. Und da war eben die Frage, ob sein Fußball dazu passt. Aber um Zerriketten herum erst mal zu gucken, dass man einfach mehr Tore schießt als der Gegner, das fand ich logisch irgendwie. Und Stand jetzt funktioniert so einigermaßen. Es funktioniert ja nicht sehr gut, weil jetzt kein Goldenergriff oder so. Aber es funktioniert so einigermaßen. Man ist etwas besser als in den Wochen zuvor. Deswegen steht man jetzt ja überm Strich. Also dementsprechend, ich fühle mich weder bestätigt noch überrascht, weil ich da sehr ergebnisoffen tatsächlich in die Personalie gegangen bin. Und jetzt gilt auch da, man hat es in der eigenen Hand. Es ist das Spiel. Also Düsseldorf gegen Fürth. Hui! Also ganz Druck auf dem Kissen.
Hat es was für Feinschmecker?
Das ist ein bisschen wie in der 1. Liga Pauli Wolfsburg. Das kanntest du vorher ja nicht. Also mittlerweile macht er, glaube ich, eine KI auf den Spielplan, weil einfacher, aber selbst die kann ja nicht voraussehen, wie es teilweise laufen wird dann in der Saison. Das konnte keiner wissen. Und Düsseldorf fürth in Fürth, das wird interessant. Also ich bin sehr gespannt. Natürlich gehen die Mannschaften jetzt mit sehr unterschiedlich Form vorzeichen. Dazu kommen wir ja gleich in diese Partie. Was kann man sagen?
Ja, da gehe ich komplett mit. Ist natürlich eine gute Nachricht, ehrlich gesagt, für alle anderen Mannschaften drum herum, dass es eben dieses direkte Duell noch gibt, weil es kann eben nur...
Einer wird verlieren? Naja, ne, stimmt nicht.
Also in der Theorie kann aber nur eine der beiden Mannschaften 3 Punkte holen.
Ja.
Und das ist ja schon mal per se für viele andere Vereine ein gutes Zeichen. Aber ja, also was dann natürlich das Problem ist, der 5. wird fehlen wegen seiner 5. gelben Karte.
Oh, das hatte ich noch gar nicht mitgeschnitten. Ach du Heilige, das verändert ja alles. Okay, du hast wieder auf das abgestiegen. Vergisst alles, was ich gerade gesagt habe.
Also wenn ich das gar nicht grüe an Thorsten Wiese, der hat das nämlich in die Gruppe geschrieben. Und genau, der hat nämlich in der 64. Spielminute die gelbe Karte bekommen. Wir gucken jetzt gerade nochmal live rein, dass ich jetzt auch wirklich keinen Schwachsinn erzähle. Wir sind gleich so weit, da steht hier natürlich nicht. Wir reden kurz weiter, ich gucke in der Zwischenzeit, ob ich das hier noch finde. Doch, hier steht es auch, zwei Gelbsperren im Endspiel sogar. Also zwei Spieler werden sogar fehlen. Cedric Ditten und Matthias Zimmermann. Fehlen beide mit der gelben Karte.
Noel Futkoy ist im Spiel gegen Hertha um seine Fünfte herumgekommen. Dementsprechend wird der da spielen.
Und das könnte natürlich gerade Matthias Zimmermann auch absolute– die haben doch ja irgendwie einen Spieler mit einer gewissen Steilkraft in Düsseldorf– könnte tatsächlich, trotz der guten Ergebnisse, das könnte tatsächlich nochmal relativ ausschlaggebend sein.
Es ist ausschlaggebend, absolut.
Also wirklich, es gibt keinen ungünstigeren Zeitpunkt, sich eine fünfte Gelbe abzuholen. Kleiner Anforderungsgeschwemmer, man weiß bei Aminia Bielefeld immer noch nicht, hat mal Corvus jetzt am Freitagabend die fünfte Gelbe Karte gesehen oder nicht.
Wie, wo, wie weißt, wie kann man das nicht wissen?
Aber Webseite steht's, bei Kicker steht's nicht, beziehungsweise wurde wieder rausgenommen. Man weiß es nicht, weil man im Spielverlauf tatsächlich auch im Real Life nicht sieht, wann er denn die fünfte Gelbe Karte gesehen haben soll. Es ist sehr amüsant. Ja, ganz toll. Wir werden sehen, am Wochenende. Aber das ist dann auf jeden Fall so ein Punkt, den darf man einfach, wenn wir natürlich die Glaskugel rausholen fürs Wochenende. Ithen ist die Definition, Unterschiedspieler für Fortuna Düsseldorf.
Ithen drin statt nur dabei. Ach du, einer muss ich.
Einer und das der auch. Und das ist für mich tatsächlich der Punkt, wo ich sage so, das kann ja halt am Ende alles nichts gebracht haben, ne? Weil, also was heißt nichts gebracht, aber du hast halt trotzdem, trotzdem, ich weiß, ich wiederhole mich da, leider kein gutes Torverhältnis.
Für Düsseldorf gilt dasselbe für Braunschweig. Wenn es richtig schlecht läuft, kannst du sogar noch auf einem direkten Abschießplatz landen.
Richtig, richtig. Also nehmen wir jetzt mal an, gut, da ist es natürlich wirklich so, müsste mit 5.000 Unterschied gewinnen, sonst wird das nix.
Ne, das stimmt ja nicht. Sie müssen ja nur mit 3.000 gewinnen, weil sich ja zeitgleich Düsseldorfs Torverhältnis verschlechtert. Also ich hab's auch nochmal ausgerechnet, ein Sieg mit 3.000 Unterschied verführt und sie steigen de facto nicht direkt ab, weil dann schieben sie sich ja vor Düsseldorf.
Richtig, richtig, hast du natürlich recht. Du, wir haben ja heute schon unsere Rechenprobleme on und off eher, das ist ganz herrlich. Aber gut, dass wir uns einfach gegenseitig haben und Mathe-Avi hatte ich nicht, nur als drittes Fach. Also, ich muss das nicht können.
Ganz weit von mir weggeschoben, du.
Aber das noch als letztes Wort zu Düsseldorf, wenn wir die Glaskugel gucken, es ist tatsächlich, nachdem sie heute konnte, konnte man erst mal sagen, nach den letzten Wochen guter Ausgangslage, mit dem Blick aufs Personal könnte man sagen, vielleicht doch nicht mehr so die Idealste.
Apropos nicht die idealste Ausgangslage. Eva, wollen wir über die Arminia aus Bielefeld reden?
Ungerne. Richtig ungern. Ich habe so fast gedacht. Es ist Platz 16, man ist abgerutscht auf den 16. Tabellenplatz mit 36 Punkten, 47 zu 50 Toren, 9 Siege, 9 Unentschieden und 15 Niederlagen. Und diese 15. Niederlage, kam am Freitagabend gegen Kaiserslautern. Man ist in der Formtabelle auch auf Platz 15, weil man in den letzten fünf Spielen eben nur einen Sieg holen konnte gegen Preußen Münster. Es war ein 1-1 gegen Bochum dabei, wo man aus mehreren Gründen sagen muss, das muss man eigentlich gewinnen, aufgrund des Spielverlaufs, aufgrund der Art und Weise, wie das 1-1 fällt und tatsächlich auch aufgrund der Tatsache, dass zumindest mal ein– ich glaube, wir sind uns alle einig– sehr klarer Elfmeter nicht gegeben wurde. Hilft alles nichts. Nichtsdestotrotz darfst du am Freitagabend gegen Kaiserslautern niemals so auftreten. Früh muss Maxi Bauer ausgewechselt werden. Maximilian Großer kommt dafür rein. Man kassiert einen Stroh-dummen Elfmeter.
Das ist wirklich der Wahnsinn. Da müssen wir mal kurz drüber reden. Das ist ja wirklich die Definition von gebrauchter Tag in diesen ersten Minuten des Spiels. Also wie Handwerker da in– ich weiß es gar nicht, was es am Ende war, in den er da reingerauscht ist.
Der hat beiden Schorle getrunken.
So nämlich. Hattest du dir auch absolut verdient. Genau so macht man es. Hefe. Hefe. Ich habe die wirklich als unbeteiligt, ich habe die Hände über den Kopf zusammengeschnallt. Wie kann man das machen?
Ja. Es war, also zusätzlich auch, war ja Daniel Jara, Cheftrainer für die Partie, bei Mitch Cleon nach dem Spiel gegen den VfL Bochen, die rote Karte gesehen hat. Einfach vielleicht kurz meine zwei Cents dazu. Natürlich sollte man niemanden, und das schiebe ich schon mal vorweg, er hat auch niemanden als geisteskrank bezeichnet, sondern die Situation, in der er abgefiffen wurde, als geisteskrank bezeichnet. Das Wort sollte man nicht nutzen, es ist eh ballistisch. Das sollten alle wissen. Und das finde ich auch nicht in Ordnung. Trotzdem könnte man eventuell ein bisschen nachfragen, wie viel Fingerspitzengefühl von Tobias Stieler in dem Moment an den Tag gelegt wurde, dafür dann direkt die rote Karte zu zeigen. Weil es ist, also die Frage ist, und das würde ich Tobias Stieler tatsächlich unterstellen, hätte er mit Kniet gesagt, er findet es unglücklich, in dem Moment abzufeifen, ob Tobias Stieler dann eventuell auch trotzdem die rote Karte gezeigt hätte.
Und ich sag mal so, Pele Wollitz und ich. Ein Satz, der mit Pele Wollitz und ich anfängt, ist immer ein komischer. Aber wir stimmen nicht oft überein. Aber da musste ich ihm Recht geben, weil er das jetzt, hatte er das nach seinem eigenen Spiel, glaube ich, angesprochen oder davor, wo er nämlich mit Kniet in Schutz genommen hat und gesagt hat, also da wollte er quasi das Größefass aufmachen, Fingerspitzengefühl von Trainern, bei Trainern, von Schiedsrichtern oder auch Spielern, weil er sagt, da ist maximal Druck auf dem Kessel. So, für Bielefeld geht es um alles. Und wenn das der Satz, der sehr gefallen ist, dann empfindet er es als eben unglücklich und als fehlendes Fingerspitzengefühl, wenn der Schiedsrichter so entscheidet. Und da würde ich absolut mitgehen. Wenn es eine persönliche Beleidigung oder ähnliches gewesen wäre, dann brauchen wir nicht lange drüber schnacken, dann ist das zu viel. Wäre immer noch irgendwie zu erklären gewesen, aber nicht zu entschuldigen. Und so empfinde ich es als drüber. Und ich glaube, da gab es auch die längere Geschichte, dass man eh bei Stieler nicht das Gefühl hatte, dass er sonderlich kommunikativ aufgestellt ist. Viel verschiedenster.
Also ich muss es tatsächlich sagen.
Ich möchte das auch noch mal betonen, dass ich nachhinein hatte, ich da mitbekommen, was der Satz waren, was so, ach, darum ging es echt? Ja krass, okay, das ist tatsächlich wahnsinnig wenig. Und da beachtet man nicht, um was es da gerade für Bielefeld geht.
Naja, und mit Kniet ist auch nicht auf ihn zugestürmt. Ja, also auch das könnte ich verstehen, wenn er, also gerade wenn mit Kniet auf mich zugestürmt kommen würde, würde ich auch erstmal weglaufen, ehrlich gesagt. Aber das ist einfach, also, bei so einem wichtigen Spiel auch seine Art und Weise hinterher zu kommunizieren. Weil Stieler hat sich selber zum Beispiel zum Verhalten nicht geäußert. Mit Kniet hat direkt danach am Mikrofon gesagt, ey, ich darf es so nicht sagen, es tut mir total leid, darf mir so nicht passieren. Und ich finde es dann irgendwie schon ein bisschen belastend in dem Moment, dass ein Trainer dann mehr Reflektion zeigt, als der Schiedsrichter, der ihm die rote Karte gegeben hat. Aber gut, das wollte ich einmal noch sagen. Nichtsdestotrotz muss man einfach sagen, du hast, glaube ich, in diesem Spiel noch mal sehr deutlich gemerkt, dass es eben gerade im Abschluss vorne an Qualität, also angeblich, ich sage mal, also ich hatte noch nie in meinem Leben ein Spiel, wo Stadionwahrnehmung und ein Blick auf die Statistiken danach auseinandergegangen sind. Also ich weiß nicht, wo ich war, als es die 20 Torschüsse gab, anscheinend nicht anwesend, aber man muss auch da sein, die Qualität der Torschüsse war trotz einem X-Golz-Wert von 1,54, was halt bei 20 Torschüssen immer noch verschwunden ist.
Das muss man eben sagen, das stücke sich dann in sehr wenig auf auf einmal.
Ja, doch durchaus sehr belassend und man muss einfach sagen, nach dem Sieg gegen Münster war ich ja auch vorsichtig positiv und man muss auch sagen, ich betone das gerne nochmal, ich fand auch, das Bochum-Spiel hat von der Leistung dann her gepasst. Dass Bielefeld auswärts schwach ist, ist auch keine neue Info. Aber die Art und Weise, und das ist wirklich was, ich habe hier in der letzten Sendung die Mannschaft, den Verein in Schutz genommen. Die Art und Weise, wie man Freitag aufgetreten ist, war für viele, viele Bielefeld-Fans eine ganz böse Rückbesinnung an diese Saison vor drei Jahren. Als man das Gefühl hatte, der Mannschaft auf dem Platz ist nicht so ganz klar, worum es geht. Ich glaube auch hier, dass Arminia im Gegensatz vielleicht zu ein, zwei anderen Vereinen den psychologischen Vorteil hat, dass man schon mal mit dem Rücken zur Wand stand und damals halt eben um einige schlimmer vor zwei Jahren.
Du, der Vorteil heißt Theater-BSC.
Nein, ich mache hier gar keine Vorteile mehr. Es meinten auch alle, der Vorteil ist Erster, Erste, Kaiserslautern, weil guck mal, wie die spielen und ja.
Fair, fair.
Ich meine, für den FCK freut es mich. Die haben nach, also generell, man hat irgendwie nach drei Spielen, die man verloren hat und absolut bodenloser Stimmung zu Hause eben da, dann nochmal die Fans mitnehmen können. Oh gut, es war auch, also liebe Grüße an die ganzen ersten FCK-Fans, die ich getroffen habe, die waren alle sehr nett und meinten so, hey, wenigstens euer Support war klasse. Und ich so, hm, danke, Zupi, das ist immer schön zu hören.
Ich hab freigesprochen und viele Bilder benutzt.
Ja, genau, ich dachte, das ist, hm, stets bemüht, toll. Aber das war, also...
Was meinst du, also du sagtest jetzt, man hatte das Gefühl, dass die nicht wissen, worum es geht. Das kann ich mir als Außenstehender nicht richtig vorstellen, bei dieser Truppe, die gefühlt nur über Mentalität kommt. Ist es vielleicht auch am Ende, man steht ja jetzt schon, also... Bielefeld steht jetzt relativ schon lange da unten jetzt wieder richtig drin. Und, ja, es gab zum Beispiel auch das Spiel in Elbersberg, wo man wirklich, wo es ein starkes Stück war, aber wo man auch, ich hab das Gefühl, es geht auch langsam wirklich die Kraft aus. Also, weil, glaubst du, war das ein Kopfding, war das ein Kraftding. Ich würde als Außenstehender erst mal naiv darauf tippen, keiner hat an dem Tag so richtig zu 100 Prozent gefunden, dann weißt du eben doch, worum es geht, verkrampft es vielleicht, ich weiß es nicht. Aber mir würde es sehr fern liegen, wie gesagt, als Außenstehender, dieser Mannschaft fehlende Mentalität zu unterstellen.
Ja, also in der Theorie schon. Es ist halt natürlich schon einfach so am Ende des Tages, es gab eben auch große Diskussionen in der Biegelfeldbubble auf Blue Sky, so was ich mitbekommen habe. Weil man halt aber schon irgendwie, also manchmal hatte man dann schon das Gefühl, so die richtige, also dieser Fighting Spirit, der im Spiel gegen Münster da war, wo du trotz Rückstand irgendwie das Gefühl hattest, okay, hier wird jetzt alles trotzdem dafür getan, zu gewinnen. Das hat mir halt einfach nach dem 1-0 gefehlt. Weil klar, das ist natürlich auch bitter, wenn du dann auch nicht einen klassischen Trainer in der Seitenlinie hast. Du musst früh wechseln, du kriegst früh diesen Elber. Das ist alles schwierig, aber trotzdem musst du dich halt fragen, ob du in dem Spiel alles gegeben hast. Und das Einzige, was ich da positiv sehe, ist, dass Jonas Kersgen als Torhüter nach dem Spiel gesagt hat, brauchen wir nicht schönreden. Das war unter aller Sau, weil ehrlich gesagt, zum Beispiel nach dem 1-1 gegen Nürnberg war schon so, dass man ja, wir haben ja per se nicht schlecht gespielt, wo ich mir dachte, ja, also es war schon einer der schlechteren Heimspiele. Also das einzige Positive, was ich sehe, dass man zu Hause bisher, bis auf das Nürnberg-Spiel vielleicht in den letzten Wochen keinen richtigen Totalausfall hatte zu Hause. Also die Ausfälle, die man hatte, das war das Auswärtsspiel in Kaiserslautern, das war das Auswärtsspiel in Karlsruhe. Und eben das Auswärtsspiel in Elbersberg. Da muss man halt einfach schon sagen, wo man sich im Zweifel auch das Torverhältnis leider noch mal so ein bisschen in Anführungszeichen versaut hat. Minus drei ist immer noch voll in Ordnung. Aber das würde ich halt sagen, es war sowieso so, dass die Auswärtsspiele eher das Problem waren. Und ich glaube, zu Hause gegen Hertha, da kommt dann schon nochmal eine andere Energie irgendwie mit und muss aber auch. Also das ist vielleicht einfach schon mal mein, ich nutze das jetzt nochmal als Ampel. Es muss halt am Sonntag genau das sein, was die letzten zwei Jahre gegolten hat. Es geht nur zusammen. Also es bringt überhaupt nichts, wenn am Sonntag jetzt bei jedem Ballverlust irgendwie ausgefiffen wird, sondern wir müssen wirklich schauen, dass wir das, was diese Mannschaft die letzten zwei Jahre ausgezeichnet hat und das ist eigentlich eben nie aufzugeben, immer wieder an sich zu glauben, immer wieder auch in Kombination mit den Fans, da alles rauszuhauen. Und das geht am Sonntag nur zusammen. Und also ganz ehrlich, wer am Sonntag dann nur hingeht, um am Ende des Spiels zu sagen, so ich hab's immer gesagt, der Knie hat, der ist es nicht, dann bleibt doch bitte einfach zu Hause, die Karten wird man los.
Fair enough. Ich glaube, um noch meine drei Cents zu dem Lauternspiel, ich glaube, was man da fernab jeder Mentalität und so weiter noch mal gesehen hat, ist, also wenn Bielefeld in der Liga bleibt, müssen sie nächstes Jahr definitiv an der Kreativabteilung arbeiten. Das Kriieren von Torchancen fällt dieser Mannschaft aus eigenem Ballbesitz heraus einfach immens schwer. Du hast bis auf Mumulu gefühlt keinen einzigen Spieler, der einen 1 gegen 1 auflösen kann. Die letzten Pässe, da hast du auch nicht die klaren Spieler für. Ja, ein Wölk kann es eventuell mal. Manchmal kann es auch von aus dem Halbraum heraus auch so jemand wie Rochelt. Aber dir fehlt fußballerische Klasse. Ja, die sind alle Mentalitätsspieler. Ja, die laufen alle sehr, sehr viel und sind sehr gut in Zweikampf und so weiter. Das hat ja sehr viel von Bielefeld in den letzten Jahren ausgemacht, um Gottes Willen. Und das ist natürlich auch die teuerste Spielklasse, quasi Spielerklasse, solche Spieler zu bekommen. Du wirst aber nächstes Jahr nicht drum herumkommen. Du brauchst ein paar Zocker mit dem Team, weil sonst läufst du dich irgendwann auch stumpf. Du brauchst einfach irgendwie Ideen. Und das hast du dann gemerkt gegen Lautern, nachdem sie geführt haben und so und auch wussten, dass Bielefeld muss, dass Bielefeld nicht so richtig kann. Also ich finde, das gehört noch zur Geschichte dieser Mannschaft dazu.
Genau. Und das ist ja auch das, was ich vor zwei Wochen gesagt habe. Ich kann da weiterhin Michael Mutzel keinen so richtigen Vorwurf machen, das nicht im Sommer schon angegangen zu haben, weil diese Mannschaft komplett zu zerreißen, wäre halt auch, also das würde halt auch komplett schief gehen können, weil wir haben eben auch gesehen, was passiert bei Komplettumbrüchen. Das kann eben in beide Richtungen gehen. Und ich weiß es nicht, ob man, also wie gesagt, man hört eben auch nicht nur Positives über so ein paar Umgänge, vielleicht mit Knien, mit seinen Spielern.
Ich sag das aber da auch gerne. Dann wirst du aber selten von einem Trainer haben.
Und ich sag das aber trotzdem auch gerne hier nochmal. Niemand ist größer als der Verein. Und also ich weiß dann halt immer nicht, ihr habt dann halt, ja, das sind Spieler, die standen im Pokalfinale, sind aufgestiegen, haben halt für ihre erste, zweite Saison vielleicht eine durchschnittliche gespielt. Aber ich frag mich dann also, ohne mit Knien, ständet ihr ehrlich gesagt auch nicht da, wo ihr dort steht und hättet nicht das Schaufenster bekommen, ehrlich gesagt. Und ich gehe weiterhin davon aus, dass da wird sich niemand im Sommer hinsetzen und sagen, jo, weiter so, weil das war nach der ersten Drittliga-Saison auch nicht der Fall, wo man fast abgestiegen ist. Aber man darf halt auch einfach nicht vergessen, wo Bielefeld aus den letzten drei Jahren herkommt und dass man da nicht direkt wieder das finanzielle Risiko geht. Das sage ich auch gerne nochmal, wem das nicht bewusst war. Und wir haben hier so oft darüber gesprochen, wie schwierig der Transfermarkt ist. Und ich meine, Marc, du kannst da von Lieds singen, wie selbst Vereine, die sagen, auf dem Papier haben wir einen guten Kader und sehr gute Einzelspieler, die das im Endeffekt halt nichts bringt, wenn du das nicht konstant auf den Platz bekommst. Und deshalb, ja, individuelle Klasse ist nicht immer der Schlüssel zum Erfolg. Aber sonst unterspreche ich alles, was du gesagt hast. Und was machen wir dann jetzt? Also, von individueller Klasse und Hertha BSC. Wie ist da jetzt die perfekte Überleitung zu unserem letzten Verein?
Die Überleitung ist, dass Hertha BSC vielleicht genau wegen dieser individuellen Klasse dieses Spiel gegen Fürth gewonnen hat. Denn anders ist das nicht zu erklären, dass Fürth dieses Spiel im Olympiastadion am Sonntag verliert. Vielleicht mal kurz zur Ausgangslage. Die Spielvereinigung Fürth, die ja sich sehr darum bemüht, dass es nicht mehr Greuther Fürth heißt, steht mit 34 Zählern jetzt auf Rang 17. Zwei Punkte hinter Bielefeld und drei hinter Düsseldorf, so wie Braunschweig. Dazu hat man das klar schwächste Torverhältnis. Also ein direkter Klassenhalt, das schiebe ich mal vorweg, der ist schon sehr unwahrscheinlich. Das muss man so sagen. Man müsste sich am ehesten in die Relegation retten. Da ist man eben zum einen davon abhängig, dass man gewinnt und zum anderen, dass Bielefeld eben nicht gewinnt. Ich glaube, da muss Bielefeld gewinnen. Also wenn sie einen Punkt holen, dann reicht es schon wieder nicht aufgrund der Tor-Differenz. Also man ist ja jetzt wirklich sehr abhängig von anderen Teams. Zu dem Spiel jetzt gegen Hertha, ja, ich glaube, das ist, also es war eine unverdiente Niederlage. Machen wir es mal ganz kurz. Hertha sieht irgendwann in Person von Josep Brejkalo eine sehr unglückliche rote Karte, die okay war aufgrund der Situation, aber sie ist für Brejkalo persönlich sehr unglücklich. Es ist auch sehr unglücklich, dass er jetzt schon wieder eine rote Karte sieht für etwas, was er nicht selber verbrochen hat. Naja, passt zur Hertha-Saison, darum soll es nicht gehen. Ab diesem Zeitpunkt war Düsseldorf, Düsseldorf, Fürth ein Mann mehr. Vorher war das Spiel wirklich nicht gut von beiden Seiten. Es gab eine Chance von Futkoi, die er wahrscheinlich sogar reinmachen muss, auch wenn er sich da sehr um die eigene Achse drehen muss. Und dann fehlt oft dann die Orientierung. Aber trotzdem kann man sagen, bei der Form, die er hat, kann er schon mal machen. Abseits dessen war es von beiden Mannschaften nichts. Und dann baut sich mit der Zeit natürlich, weil du ein Mann mehr bist, Druck auf. Du versuchst, mehr nach vorne zu gehen, weil du irgendwie auch musst. Und dann kassierst du aber ein Gegentor. Das hat mit Profifußball nichts zu tun. Das war wirklich unfassbar. Jetzt kann man sagen, ja, Kenneth Eichhorn, dass der mit 16 Jahren dieses Dribbling überhaupt wagt. Das spricht dann wieder für die Klasse und den Mut dieses 16-Jährigen. Und das ist irre. Auf der anderen Seite stehen da 5 Vierter und tu nix. Tu einfach gar nix. Das ist unfassbar gewesen. Da siehst du einfach, dass Viert, also Heiko Vogel hat ein paar Dinge geschafft, aber diesen defensiven Schlendrian und diese unerklärlichen Dinge, die da passieren, die hat er auch eher nicht dieser Mannschaft austreiben können. Das zweite Gegentor, was dann ja quasi durch das Spiel so ein bisschen entscheidet, das musst du in der Entstehung besser verteidigen. Da darf Karbovnik und Co. einfach zu viel machen, dass dieser Schuss von Cuisance dann kommt, wie er kommt. Ja, das ist dann bitter, aber du musst es in der Entstehung besser verteidigen. Du kommst durch Futtkoll sogar noch mal ran. Aber das große Problem waren an dem Tag zum einen, dass du defensiv zwei, drei Mal wirklich amateurhaft aussaust und dir das nicht erlauben kannst zu diesem Zeitpunkt der Saison. Das geht nicht. Und das andere ist, dass du vorne wirklich atemberaubend schwach warst im Abschluss. Futtkoll hätte eigentlich noch über sein Tor hinaus zwei Tore machen müssen. Hurgotha hatte eine sehr gute Chance. Felix Klaus hatte gefühlt vier gute Chancen. Der eingewechselte Hiegel hatte eine gute Chance. Ja, Hertha hat sich in alles dann irgendwo heroisch reingeworfen. Und dann kann man das aus Hertha-Sicht mit Wille und ähnlichem erklären. Aus Vierter Sicht eine maximal unnötige Niederlage, die eben wehtut, weil selbst wenn du einfach nur einen Punkt mitnimmst, hast du eben die Möglichkeit, dass selbst wenn Bielefeld unentschieden spielt, du vor sie ziehen kannst. Also selbst wenn du einen Punkt hättest, du dir eine bessere Aushangslage für den letzten Spieltag geschaffen. Jetzt bei diesem Spiel dann eben gegen Düsseldorf, wo der maximale Druck drauf liegt. Man hat so gespielt, dass irgendwann der Support eingestellt wurde bei Viert, weil das ist irgendwie bitter gewesen, weil man hat ja mit der Truppe schon angesehen, dass sie wollte. Sie hat versucht, aber natürlich ist man da nicht mehr rein rational als Fan. Die haben sich danach auch ordentlich was anhören dürfen aus der Gäste-Kurve. Die haben mir fast leidgetan, weil ich so dachte, naja, eigentlich hat ja nur das Tor gefehlt. Aber du differenzierst an dem Zeitpunkt als Fan natürlich auch nicht mehr so krass. Und ich bin sehr gespannt. Auch da glaube ich, dass sich viele darauf besinnen werden, ey, Heimspiel, letzte Chance. Die tun auch mal alles dafür. Alle stellen sich hinter den Verein und wir supporten. Aber da hast du wieder so einen Bruch gemerkt. Am Ende mache ich mir schon sehr viel Sorgen um Fird, weil sie am instabilsten von allen wirken.
Ja, man muss halt sagen, in dem Sinne muss man die Fans fast ein bisschen in Schutz auch nehmen, weil du hattest jetzt das zweite Spiel ja eigentlich in Folge, wo du sagst, naja, das musst du gewinnen im Frankendorbi gegen Nürnberg. Hast du das 1-1? Nürnberg mehr Torschüsse, aber führt da eigentlich die höhere Qualität an Torschüssen. Dann wird unter der Woche bekannt, Brandy Mio Gotra verlässt den Verein nach gefühlt 120 Jahren jetzt auch mal. Etwas, das man, wenn man ehrlich ist, sich ja auch langsam aber sicher angedeutet hat, dass der nicht den Gang mit in die dritte Liga geht, sollte der anstehen, war klar, ob das kommunikativ jetzt der richtige Zeitpunkt war.
So wie ich es rückbekommen habe, war es so, dass das einfach zu sehr schon nach außen gedrungen ist und dann wahrscheinlich der Verein, das quasi mit die Flucht nach vorne angetreten ist.
Genau. Also es war jetzt auch gar kein Vorwurf an Rukgota oder Führt. Es ist immer die Frage, wer da halt Informationen durchsticht. Aber ich glaube, da können viele Vereine ein Lied von singen. Und dann ist es halt wirklich einfach. Und das meine ich mit dem, die Fans in Schutz nehmen. Du hattest eben die Spiele gerade in der Rückrunde, wo du vielleicht nicht unbedingt die bessere Mannschaft warst, wo du trotzdem die Punkte mitgenommen hast.
Das stimmt.
Aber du kannst halt zu diesem Zeitpunkt der Saison wahrscheinlich einfach nicht mehr sagen so, ja, hey, ist doch alles top. Hey, ist doch super. Und man muss dann halt auch sagen…
Nee, nee, das wollte ich ja sagen. Die Differenz-Jugend bleibt dann irgendwann einfach auf der Strecke.
Und weil du halt eben sagen musst, hey, wenn das Spiel 0-0 ausgeht, okay, ist immer noch nicht ideal, weil dir vielleicht vorne einfach die Qualität fehlt. Aber wie du eben auch schon gesagt hast, die Art und Weise, wie vor allem das 0 zu 1 fällt, das darf halt nicht passieren. Und das siehst du als Fan natürlich auch. Und das ist eben, glaube ich, das Tragische. Und da muss man einfach sagen, Fjord war so wie meine Top-Pflanzen bei mir zu Hause, wo ich immer zwischendurch, also ich besitze jetzt wieder keine, ich hatte mal eine, wo ich immer so dreimal dachte, kommt sie noch mal wieder? Und am Ende war es so ein sehr, war es ein Trauerspiel. Sag ich wie es ist, war es einfach ein Trauerspiel, was da übrig lief. Und man muss jetzt leider sagen, also das lag an meiner nicht vorhandenen grünen Daumenaktivität. Und bei Fjord muss man einfach sagen, das reicht eben auch qualitativ einfach nicht. Da ist halt, sie haben den kreativen Spieler mit Noel Furtkoy. Also das ist ja trotzdem immer noch, der hat, also ohne Noel Furtkoy, wer führt, glaube ich, noch um einiges. Also da wäre der Abstieg schon sehr viel früher statt. Aber man muss schon sagen, es fällt einem wirklich, wirklich schwer, trotz der Sachen, bei denen wir gerade über Düsseldorf gesprochen haben, wie das reichen soll. Und auch, also selbst wenn sie es noch schaffen in die Relegation, also auch da wissen wir noch nicht, wen wir da von unten kommen.
Nö, bunte Tüte.
Absolut bunte Tüte. Also das wird für viele Vereine schwierig, weil anders als in der Ausstiegsrelegation, ist in der Abstiegsrelegation tatsächlich meistens der Drittligist im Vorteil. Also eben auch viel über die Qualität der beiden Ligen aussagt. Aber ja, ich sehe tatsächlich und ich glaube da, also das ist auch was da, da wird uns Michi Fischer auch bei unterstützen. Man muss, also wir haben bei Magdeburg und Dresden gesagt, nach der Saison wäre es auch nicht unverdient, drin zu bleiben nach der Art und Weise, wie man sich entwickelt hat. Bei Fürth muss man fast sagen, ja, sie haben sich zwischendurch nochmal hochgekämpft, aber über jetzt 33 Spieltage gezogen, ist die Frage, ob ein Klassenerhalt, vor allem ein direkter Klassenerhalt, in dem Falle überhaupt verdient wäre.
Da ist mal eine klare Antwort, nein. Also für mich wäre das ein verdienter Absteiger. Aber so wie es bei Bielefeld usw. gilt, du hast jetzt diesen einen Spieltag. Du hast diesen einen Spieltag, du hast ein Heimspiel. Du spielst gegen eine Mannschaft, die selber nicht das perfekte mentale Gerüst für so ein Spiel hat, mit Düsseldorf. Wie gesagt, du bist sehr von anderen Teams abhängig. Das steht ja außer Frage. Vor allen Dingen halt einfach von Bielefeld. Du musst also alles anderes eigentlich egal. Du musst halt gucken, was Bielefeld dann macht. Aber du musst erstmal deine Hausaufgaben machen, um dir ja nichts vorwerfen zu können. Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass es möglich ist, dass Fird dieses Spiel gewinnt und trotzdem absteigt, weil Bielefeld was holt gegen Hertha, das glaube ich, ist definitiv möglich. Wie Hertha die letzten Wochen auftritt, also... Da kurz der Hertha-Talk. Also Hertha ist seit Wochen richtig schlecht. Das einzig gute Spiel, und das ist dann auch noch das, was man verliert, war gegen Kiel. Das darf man auf keinen Fall verlieren, so. Das war wirklich ein Freak-Spiel dahingehend. Aber alles andere ist wirklich schlecht. Und ich sehe bei Hertha nicht, dass das am letzten Spieltag aus dem Nichts kommt, diese Truppe wirkt geschlagen, im Sinne von auch, dass da richten sich viele Blicke schon in den Sommer. Viele werden aufhören, werden gehen, aus verschiedensten Gründen. Da ist kein großer Spirit mehr drin. Das hat ja auch dieses Spiels gegen Fürth gezeigt. Solange das Elf gegen Elfer und Hertha quasi auch mehr Ballbesitzung zu hatte, war das ein grausiges Fußballspiel. Und dann gewinnst du dieses Spiel irgendwie, weil du effizient bist und hinten noch dein Kadaver dazwischen geworfen bekommst. Aber, ja, ganz ehrlich, es ist so. Ich sehe die Blitzheilung nicht vor dem Spiel gegen Bielefeld und deswegen muss sich Bielefeld da was ausrechnen. Du kannst gegen diese Hertha definitiv was holen. Und wenn es nur ein Punkt ist.
Du hast ja eben deine Prognose abgegeben, dass du sagst, die Tabelle bleibt so bei den Aussteigern. Da ist der Pool ein bisschen kleiner. Würdest du dich sogar an eine– also ich habe eben Power-Rankings so ein bisschen angesprochen. Es ist hier natürlich schon eine durchaus andere Ausgangslage. Aber was würdest du denn in Bezug auf das Abstiegskonglomerator unten sagen?
Ja, habe ich natürlich parallel so ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht. Also ich sage, dass Magdeburg und Dresden sind durch. Ich glaube, dass Düsseldorf nicht absteigt. Die werden das irgendwie hinbekommen gegen Fürth. Und wenn es irgendwie ein Punkt ist, ich sage jetzt, mein Call ist, dass Bielefeld mindestens einen Punkt holt gegen Hertha und Braunschweig aber auf Schalke verliert. Und deswegen landet Braunschweig auf dem Religationsplatz und Bielefeld rutscht noch auf Rang 15. Punktgleich aber Tor-Differenz.
Du, wenn das so ausgeht, kannst du dir schon mal, der nächste Eisbecher geht auf mich.
Stark!
Das kannst du dir schon mal merken. Was sagst denn du?
Du bist ja beteiligt, das ist immer schwierig.
Du, ich habe eben schon nichts gesagt und deshalb sage ich einfach nichts mehr.
Total fair, es ist total fair.
Ich habe mir die Grube nicht gegraben, eben du dir schon. Das ist richtig.
Das ist richtig. Gut, ich würde sagen, hast du noch was?
Ja, genau. Ich wollte einfach nur sagen, ich wünsche, auch wenn ich nicht unbeteiligt bin, trotzdem allen Teams da drunter ganz, ganz viel Kraft für den letzten Spieltag. Ja, es ist nur Fußball, aber ja, wir wissen trotzdem, es ist manchmal die schönste, manchmal die schlimmste Nebensache der Welt. Und da deshalb einfach schon mal passt auf euch auf, am nächsten Sonntag, wo immer ihr auch unterwegs seid, habt vielleicht was Schönes nach 17.30 geplant. Und ich wünsche natürlich euch nicht allen das Erreichen des Saisonziels, weil das geht dann leider nicht so ganz auf. Aber ja, haltet gut durch. Und ich glaube, es wird noch eine Abschlussfolge geben, aber ich sag trotzdem schon mal auch, ihr Marques, hat mir sehr, sehr viel Spaß gemacht mit dir diese Saison. Und ich fand das auch sehr cool. Und da gerne auch, also wenn ihr Feedback nicht nur zu der Folge habt, aber natürlich auch generell zu dem Format. Es hat mir sehr Spaß gemacht, zwischendurch auch mal diese zwei Erfolgen einzustreuen, weil das, glaube ich, auch ja für sowohl für die Hörer erinnern als auch für uns nochmal immer ein guter Feedback-Kreis irgendwie war.
Total. Ich drücke schon mal aufs Outro und gebe das genauso zurück, Eva. Das hat mir ganz großen Spaß gemacht, auch in diesem neuen Modus jetzt mit unseren Allstars. Sehr, sehr geile Geschichte. Ich habe das Gefühl, das ist eine richtig eingestrohene Truppe draus geworden. Ich möchte gar keinen verlieren jetzt durch den Abstieg. Mach das mal nicht, ey. Das ist eine Katastrophe. Naja, vielen lieben Dank fürs Zuhören. Vielen lieben Dank für die Unterstützung in Kommentaren in Form von Spenden. Das wissen wir alles sehr zu schätzen. Und wie gesagt, Saisonrückblick wird es geben. Bis dahin, machts gut. Ciao, ciao.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.